So, Leute, bin ich am Start, ha ha, ja ja, guck mal, die Katze liegt immer noch auf dem Chat, sehe ich gerade.
Jo, nochmal 97 Dankeschön für den Sub, 20 Monate, huge Subscriber.
Guck mal, Chainlord ist auch, da hast du gesehen, was ich gepostet habe im Emote, in dem Vorschläge Channel, also das Kocona Emote, das wäre richtig nice, wenn man das mit dem anderen Keks machen könnte, also mit dem, mit dem, der nicht so Poggers guckt, sondern mit dem anderen Keks.
Das würde ich auch gleich nehmen, weil so ein richtiges Wupp gekommnet wird, wäre schon nice.
Nee, ich meine jetzt, das würde ich, das würde ich auf Twitch direkt machen, aber ja.
Ach so, deine, deine Slots sind voll.
Ja gut, aber direkt auf Twitch kann ich ja machen.
Da wegen den vollen Slots kann man sich also überlegen, das kann ich ja auch einreichen bei den.
Ja, das ist der neue Keks auf dem Thumbnail, ja das ist richtig. Siehst du was ich wieder komisch finde, YouTube ist echt merkwürdig, ich kann, also ich kann mir auf YouTube immer keinen Reim machen.
Normalerweise ist es so, wenn die Videos am Anfang gut laufen, dann laufen die in der Regel auch die restliche Zeit gut. Und dann hast du jetzt irgendwie so Videos, die letzten paar Videos, also die letzten zwei, gut das waren Ostern, das haben nicht so viele gesehen glaube ich, aber die waren so, so recht gut, dann ziemlich gut und dann hat es auf einen Schlag keiner mehr geguckt.
Ganz merkwürdig, Alter. Ich blicke, ich blicke da durch, aber ich glaube, ich habe es, wie gesagt, ich habe es eh schon aufgegeben, da irgendwie YouTube zu verstehen. Ist einfach nur Dauer-Cack-Waiten, Alter.
Was hast du Tipps für die EU Cup? Warum habe ich keinen Chat auf? Ach, das ist der Frasier-Chat, wundere mich schon, warum ich keinen Chat sehe, Alter. Battlefield 3 Gameplay habe ich ja auch gemacht.
Die letzten Videos hast du von deinen alten Videos geklaut. Welche letzten Videos? Das ist ja die Mehrzahl, das will ich jetzt wissen. Echt nicht? Ah, YouTube, YouTube, okay Champ.
Die letzten zwei, so, so. Von welchem Video habe ich denn, von welchem Video habe ich denn das hier geklaut? Ich meine, da habe ich vor sieben Jahren schon mal was zu gemacht, allerdings nicht ganz so ausführlich, okay.
Aber wo habe ich das denn geklaut? Da kann ich mich ja selbst immer dran erinnern. Du kriegst YouTube-Notifications über Discord? Ja, das ist eh Big Brain.
Excellent, excellent. Ja, Celo, den Song habe ich gehört. Das habe ich gehört.
Oh, Leute, ich bin müde, ey. What the fuck? Also, ähm, also, über die Ausbildung hast du schon mal geredet? Oh nein, ernsthaft?
Ja, da habe ich schon öfters drüber geredet. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass man das mal in einem 5-Minuten-Video, ich rede heute mal über die Ausbildung.
Nee, nee, nee, Captain Peng, das meine ich nicht. Ich meine das von heute, was angeblich auch irgendwo abgeguckt war.
Pequate. Ähm, ja, also zu der Frage mit Tipps für die Abschlussprüfung, den einzigen Tipp, den ich wirklich habe, der auch wirklich funktioniert für die Abschlussprüfung ist, alte Prüfung machen, easy, sowas. Ach, by the way, das trifft sich tatsächlich gut.
Ich habe sogar, ich habe vorhin mal geschaut, ob es IHK-Prüfungen gibt, die nicht copyright-mäßig, also, ne, die normalen IHK-Prüfungen, die darf man ja, darf man ja sich downloaden und so, da sagt keiner was, aber ich darf die halt nicht zeigen.
Ich habe das hier, das hier vorhin gefunden, das ist irgendwie eine Leseprobe von so einer Prüfung, von so einem Prüfungsvorbereitungsding über, über YouTube, das ist irgendwie eine Leseprobe und guck mal, da sind Testfragen drin, die könnte man mal im Stream zusammen machen, mal gucken wie sehr ich verkacke, ey.
Pequate. Guck dir, so eine typische IHK, typische IHK-Crap, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, alter.
Ja, da zu dem Thema habe ich schon total viele Videos gemacht.
Pequate. Du hast übel Schiss vor den Prüfungen, warum? Also, was, warum konkret? Weil, vor der, eher vor der schriftlichen oder vor dem Präsentieren?
Weil, vor den schriftlichen ist das Beste was du machen kannst, die alten IHK-Prüfungen. Mach alte IHK-Prüfungen. Der Kram ist immer der gleiche Scheiß, nur leicht abgewandelt. Es ist immer der gleiche Müll.
Die Firma heißt mal ein bisschen anders, die Netze heißen mal ein bisschen anders, aber das schwierigste an der IHK-Prüfung ist, so ein bisschen in diese IHK-Frage, Frage-Style reinzukommen.
Genau. Hättest du die Antworten von der alten IHK-Prüfung würdest du die Copy-Pasten. Würdest du wahrscheinlich sogar bestehen damit.
Habe ich mal eine Frage an die Leute, die auch IHK-Abschlussprüfungen gemacht haben. Welchen Teil habt ihr gestrichen? Den Visoteil kann man leider nicht streichen, den hätte ich sonst sofort gestrichen.
Welchen Teil habt ihr gestrichen? Ich habe strukturierte Verkabelung gestrichen. Das was jeder gemacht hat und dafür habe ich den Programmierteil gemacht.
Ich glaube Struktogramm musste ich malen und irgendwie Bugs finden, die total offensichtlich waren.
Aber UML kommt in der Abschlussprüfung eigentlich selten. Ja ich weiß die meisten Leute haben den Programmierteil gestrichen, ich habe Strukturierte Verkabelung gestrichen.
Was ist denn Strukturierte Verkabelung? Nein nein nein, da geht es um Netzwerkverkabelung. So nach dem Motto, du stellst einen Switch auf jedes Stockwerk, einen größeren Switch in jeden Standort und sowas in der Richtung.
Du vergibst ein paar IP-Adressen und das ist Strukturierte Verkabelung. Komm mal die Katze beobachtet uns. Also es geht um simpelste Dinge und das macht eigentlich jeder.
Ja es ist eh der Wahnsinn. Die IRK ist ja auch der Meinung man ist zur Hälfte Kaufmann, was totaler Schwachsinn ist. Niemand den ich da in der Klasse hatte hat sich gefreut auf irgendwelche Wirtschaftssachen.
Die IRK ist der Meinung, ja das muss man wissen und man muss irgendwelche komischen Gantdiagramme machen können, ist ja immer noch ein absolutes Lieblingsding hier. Huge Gantdiagramme, wer macht nicht gerne Gantdiagramme?
Und wisst ihr was noch viel besser ist als das Gantdiagramm? Das Ishikawa Diagramm, noch noch besser. Also wenn man das nicht auswendig kann, dieses komischen Fisch hier, dann ist eh vorbei.
Dove Frage, hat das wirklich schon mal einer in freier Wildbahn gesehen? Ich hab das auch noch nie gesehen. Man kann die Kaufmannischen Aufgaben nicht streichen, das ist ein eigener Teil.
Aber sowas hier, wer benutzt das? Gibt es wirklich Leute, die diesen Kram verwenden jetzt ernsthaft? Kegway, das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Wer benutzt sowas? Clara? Problem, Problem, Effekt, ho, super. Was ein Schwachsinn, Alter. Ja, ok, ok, wenn du Berufsschullehrer wirst, ja das verstehe ich, das verstehe ich.
Nächster Poolstream schon in Planung. Ja, das stimmt, da musst du im Endeffekt auch den Kram auswendig lernen. Da gibt es aber auch nur so eine beschränkte Anzahl an Möglichkeiten.
Nee, kein Stream. Ja, ist echt so, ist echt so. Ach, alles Crap irgendwie. Weiß auch nicht. Man muss es halt machen. Übrigens, könnt ihr euch daran erinnern, im letzten Stream, wo es so ultra gelackt hat, als wir Tasmota geflasht haben auf die Steckdose.
Wo es Hyper Poggers Lack gemacht hat. Wisst ihr was ich gemacht habe? Wo ich mich noch gefragt habe, wie kann das sein, wie kann das sein, dass das Lack, das gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich habe meine Axis Points geflasht heute. Ich habe jetzt zwei Unify Axis Points und ich habe einfach mal gedacht, ach scheiße, mach mal ein Firmware Update. Ich habe aber mal an die Axis Points geflasht und das ist fast weg. Das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Alter, was ist mit dem? Was hat der denn für... Das ist ja zum Fürchten. Naja. Bye Bane. Kek. Das Original. Kek weh. Nice. Zwei Monate eigentlich für den Sub.
Nicht Kek wait. Oder nicht Kek weh das ist. Moment. Subscriber. Exzellent. Ist das irgendwie lauter als sonst? Nee, passt eigentlich. Der ist echt nice. Den gucke ich auch immer gerne.
Nee, wie gesagt, ich habe mir vorhin gar nichts überlegt. Ich bin ja morgen früh schon wieder am Starten. Ich weiß auch gar nicht wie lange ich on bin. Übrigens, das hier hat mal einer im Discord geschickt. Das soll ich mal im Stream machen. Weiß nicht, vielleicht machen wir das heute.
Der News Test. Wie gut bist du im Umgang mit Nachrichten im Internet? Das meiste ignoriere ich ehrlich gesagt. Die einzigen Nachrichten die mich interessieren ist, ob Lieferando pünktlich ist.
Nee, das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Ich habe mir die ersten zwei, drei Fragen mal angeguckt. Das ist gar nicht so doof. Guck mal. Jaja. Jaja. Jaja. Jaja.
Guck, da musst du hier einschätzen, was das ist. Ist das Information? Ist das Werbung? Ist das Meinung? Oder ist das Falschinformation? Kann man das direkt nur droppen? Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so doof.
Kannst gleich den Political Compass machen. Da ging es gestern Abend auch darum. Was zum Teufel ist der Political Compass? Ist das der Internetführerschein? Ja, das ist der Internetführerschein für Facebook Boomer.
Ja, mach. Ja, wo müsst ihr mich schicken? Ich weiß nicht, wo das ist. Ich kenne ihn acht Monate. Danke schön für den Sub.
Teikoyoshi sagt werde jetzt für 2,62600 Euro monatlich von meinem Unternehmen innerhalb von zwei Jahren intern zum Junior Software Developer ausgebildet.
Was bist du denn aktuell? Von wo nach wo? 2600, also kommen die beiden auf dem Konto an oder ist das noch bevor du Steuern bezahlst? Weil dann bleibt dir da im Endeffekt bleiben dir ja bloß noch 1000, 1500 Euro übrig.
Da kommt man nicht so weit mit. Political Compass. Okay. Oh, Sekunde. Oh, übelst. Niesstelz. Okay, also was? Ja, welche Seite denn jetzt?
Testen ob die rechts, links, radikal oder liberal bist. Anzeige ist raus. Das ist auch noch auf Englisch. Das ist auch noch auf Englisch. Da muss man Big Brain sein wieder.
In my homeland Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat. Kann das nicht auf Englisch machen. So. Lies bitte die Homepage. Hä?
Wie? Warum soll ich, warum soll ich die Homepage lesen? Keck Wade. Wollt ihr mich aufhalten? Den Test zu machen. Geht auf rechts, links, oben, Deutsch, Keck. Exquisite.
Hallo? Okay, es sind immer, es sind immer die gleichen, es sind immer die gleichen Fragen. Ich muss, ich muss aber erst noch mal, ich muss, bevor ich das mache, muss ich erst mal mein Brain einschalten, Leute.
Das dauert noch kurz. Noch ein paar, ich muss noch ein paar Minuten labern mit euch. Da muss ich erst mal mein Brain einschalten.
Weißt ihr was ich eigentlich für ein Video machen wollte? Ich wollte so, ich sag jetzt mal einen übertriebenen, ich sag mal übertriebenen Titel. Ich werd's wahrscheinlich nicht so nennen.
Aber ich weiß, dass es auf YouTube immer, egal was du sagst, dass die Leute sich da wahnsinnig darüber aufregen. Ich wollte eigentlich mal relativ, irgendwie, sofern man da neutral sein kann, mich mal zu der aktuellen Corona-Politik auslassen.
Ich mach, ich mach ja normalerweise so Videos nicht. Ja, das wisst ihr ja. Und ich werd's auch nicht, ich hab mir kurz überlegt, ob ich's nicht dann irgendwie so nach dem Motto, die Abrechnung mit der Corona-Politik oder so, pass auf, muss ja nicht, man muss es ja nicht, muss es ja nicht übertreiben.
Aber das Problem ist, im Prinzip ist es fast egal, was du sagst. Die Leute sind bei allem ultra-triggert. Triggert sein ist heute so Hobby. Alle sind bei allem triggert.
Das ist ja auch so geil, ne? Sobald du nicht hundertprozentig dafür bist, bist du instant Corona-Leute. Zumindest wenn es um Twitter geht, ja. Zumindest wenn es um Twitter geht.
Die Leute müssen halt immer klar werden, das ist meistens nicht schwarz und weiß. Also man kann durchaus Corona für existent halten und auch nicht an der Existenz von Virens zweifeln oder sagen, die Leute werden gar nicht wirklich krank, das sieht nur so aus oder was auch immer.
Und trotzdem, und trotzdem nicht zufrieden sein mit der Corona-Politik. Das ist durchaus möglich, aber das ist anscheinend, entzieht sich anscheinend der Vorstellungskraft vieler Leute, ja.
Aber hier ist ja Big Brain Chat, da gibt es also Probleme nicht. Wir skalieren ja auch diagonal, da wird nicht nur horizontal skaliert.
Also, vielleicht bist du ja schon gechipt und du machst das jetzt lächerlich, weil du davon ablenken willst, dass das in Wirklichkeit schon längst passiert ist.
Wer weiß.
Dass der gestorben ist, wusste ich nicht. Dass Prinz Philip gestorben ist, wusste ich, aber da kann ich...
Das juckt mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so großartig.
Warum sollte Bill Gates 5G benutzen, wenn es so schlecht ausgebaut ist?
Ich frage immer Fragen, ne?
Ja, der sah schon die letzten Jahre, wenn ich von ihm gesehen habe, nicht gut aus.
Nein, nein, nein, Bill Gates ist kein Echsenmensch, das stimmt nicht.
Aber der Bodyguard von Obama war ein Echsenmensch. Du musst schon mal... Mensch, informier dich doch mal. Du musst doch deine Facts schon rightgetten, ja.
Nicht einfach hier irgendwas behaupten, ohne Ahnung zu haben.
Ich habe mich informiert, ja, auf den einschlägigen Seiten dazu.
Ich weiß definitiv, auch wenn es die Allgemeinheit nicht wahrhaben will, dass Obamas Bodyguard definitiv ein Echsenmensch war.
Da sind wir uns hoffentlich einig, das ist doch allgemein bekannt, Leute, oder?
Max dreht durch.
Das ist eines der lustigsten Videos, die ich je gesehen habe, mit Obama Bodyguard Echsenmensch.
Leider findet man das nicht mehr.
Das da, das ist es, das ist es.
Wait a minute, das ist es, das ist es.
Das ist schon die ganze Zeit das Video, das ist unglaublich bescheuert, was die Leute sich da zusammenreiben.
Nein, nein, nein, nicht Alien, nicht Alien, nicht Alien, Leute, Echsenmensch, Mensch.
Echsenmensch, Alter.
Das Video geht nicht mehr.
Fuck.
Das ist so richtig geil zu schauen, dieses Video, das ist so geil, das ist so dumm, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Das kann schon sein.
Aber ich habe auch dicke Arme, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ich, ja, ich bin da normalerweise sofort dabei.
Es gibt schon, es gibt schon ein paar echt geile.
Ich habe zum Beispiel letztens einen gesehen, da hat irgendein Flat Earth Typ, hat ein Video gemacht,
und hat das vorgerechnet, wie das so ist, und hat dann gemeint, er gibt jedem, der das widerlegen kann, 10.000 Euro.
Kokona Video natürlich, was sonst, Kokona Video.
Und da haben ganz viele Leute auch drauf geantwortet, na natürlich, wer hätte das gedacht, nichts ausbezahlt.
Eigentlich ist das eine richtig geile Idee.
Tierlist, das schreibe ich mir oft zum Magisch auf Julo, Tierlist, Tierlist Verschwörungstheorien.
Es gibt schon ein paar geile, es gibt schon ein paar geile.
Aber ich muss sagen, also meine, meine, also ganz oben ist definitiv Obamas Exenmensch Bodyguard.
Bei den Amis kann man doch Leute verklagen.
Ich glaube, das hängt da ein bisschen davon ab, wie bei uns, wie er das gesagt hat.
Aber wahrscheinlich könntest du ihn verklagen, aber dann nicht auf 10.000, sondern dann gleich auf 50 Billionen.
Dann machen wir da keine, keine kalben Sachen, ja.
Chemtrails, die finde ich langweilig.
Das gibt es schon so lange.
Also ich, nein, Mondlandung im Studio finde ich auch langweilig.
Ich finde, also was ich ganz, was ich ganz gut verfinde, ist internationale Raumstation unter Wasser.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Und die Obamas Bodyguard Exenmensch finde ich gut.
Jetzt müsste ich mal, müsste ich mal in mich gehen.
Ich habe so viele Schwachsinnensvideos dazu schon geguckt, aber das sind halt so die ersten zwei, die mir, das sind halt so die ersten zwei, die mir, die mir einfallen.
Chemtrails, alles klar.
Aber die finde ich langweilig.
Chemtrails finde ich langweilig, weil das gibt es schon so lange und ist irgendwie so, so ausgelutscht.
Da muss es aber ein bisschen besser, Mondlandung, Mondlandung im Studio.
Leute, wenn einer sagt Mondlandung im Studio, passt mal auf.
First CGI hier.
1972, das ist die erste, eines der ersten CGI-Movies 1972.
Ihr wisst, wann die Mondlandung war, oder?
Chat, das enttäuscht mich nicht. Wann war die Mondlandung?
Ja, 1969, richtig.
So, guck mal.
Also, das ist eine Animation zwei Jahre nach der Mondlandung, oder drei Jahre nach der Mondlandung.
Behauptet wirklich ernsthaft jemand, man hätte mit der Technik von damals eine Mondlandung mit Kameraaufnahmen fecken können.
Klar, es gibt bestimmt immer noch Leute, die das behaupten, ja.
Aber exzellent, ja.
Du brauchst für die, also um die Videoaufnahmen von der, das waren übrigens ein FPS-Aufnahmen, die sie damals gemacht haben, oder sogar nur 0,5 FPS.
Wenn du die faken willst, die die mit der Handkamera da gemacht haben, das stelle ich mir äußerst schwierig vor ohne CGI.
Oh, mit CGI war damals halt nicht so viel.
Zehnt meine Telegram-Gruppe als Quelle. Telegram ist, wissen wir alle samt, ist eigentlich eines der seriösesten Nachrichtenquellen überhaupt.
Illuminati-Verschwörung ist auch out. Das war mal so angesagt zu Zeiten, wo diese Bücher voll aktuell waren, aber aktuell ist Illuminati auch langweilig.
Naja, ungefähr sowas war das ja auch. Kamera, Mondlandung, das war ja quasi eine Kamera, die einzelne Fotos gemacht hat.
Sowas in der Richtung, das haben die in die Hand genommen und haben dann halt quasi, mehr oder weniger, hat das Ding einzelne Fotos gemacht.
Aber, man muss sich mal überlegen, die haben das damals schon geschafft, teilweise zu streamen mit 0,5 FPS.
Gar nicht mal so schlecht für 1969.
Spread the beast, exquisite sub. 18 Monate, das ist ja schon...
High-per-sub-scramer, high-per-sub-scramer.
Nice. Ja, ey, bei dem Arbeitsambio, ich muss ja sagen, ich hätte vielleicht noch Disclaimer einbauen sollen, muss man ja heutzutage machen.
Bei dem hier. By the way, ihr findet ja eigentlich das Thumbnail. Ich finde das Thumbnail übelst lustig, aber es hat, glaube ich, kaum einer realisiert, weil man es nicht richtig lesen kann.
Weil wenn man sich Thumbnails angucken will, ist es das beste, das in Firefox zu machen, weil Firefox spielt nicht automatisch ab.
Ne, macht's auch nicht.
Da sieht man das Thumbnail.
Das hat der Vettel das vorgeschlagen, das hab ich nicht, da bin ich gar nicht selbst drauf gekommen.
Was geht's los mit dem Kompass? Soll ich anfangen, ja?
Aber es haben die Leute hier nicht gecheckt.
Tja.
By the way, wenn man Firefox zugemacht hat und möchte wieder zurück, diesen Button kann auch nicht viele.
Krasse Windows-Hacks, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Das ist äußerst, äußerst wilde Hacks.
So.
Ja, die sagen ja natürlich wieder, die stecken alle unter einer Decke, ist doch ganz klar.
Ach so. Ja, das klingt logisch. Also man muss ja mal ehrlich sagen, Elon Musk hat gar nicht, hat gar nicht so viele Verschwörungstheorien, oder?
Also Bill Gates, ich weiß nicht, was die mit Bill Gates haben. Bill Gates ist ja oftmals dran schuld. Ja.
Zuckerberg ist auch teilweise Echsenmensch und Verschwörung, aber Elon Musk ist gar nicht so. Warum eigentlich? Ist er noch zu neu, oder was?
Hehe. Hey, die haben damals, glaube ich schon in ziemlich guter, ziemlich guter Auflösung aufgenommen. Ich kann euch übrigens, äh, äh, was empfehlen, was echt, ich weiß nicht, ein sehr, sehr richtig guter Auflöser ist, oder was?
die haben damals glaube ich schon in ziemlich guter ziemlich gute
auflösung aufgenommen ich kann euch übrigens was empfehlen was echt also
alle die sich ein bisschen für für weltraum stellung und mondleitung so
interessieren guckt euch den film an von 2018 oder so
das ist dokumentation die ist aber die ist als kompletter film erschienen mit
original genau das da das da den gibt es bei amazon das ist eineinhalb stunden
original aufnahmen mit dem
kommen kostet nur 3 euro 98 ja das ist drei stunden original aufnahmen eineinhalb
stunden original aufnahmen und ohne ohne commentator also sprich die haben nur
original aufnahmen genommen plus die den den damaligen missionsleiter was der
gesagt hat das ist echt gut gemacht im prinzip geht es von kurz vorher los
inklusive stadt und uns wie und aus dieser doko weiß ich auch dass der eine
ich ich glaube was all den was dass der beim start glaube einen pulz hatte von
79 oder so was da denke ich mir alter wenn ich auf dem klo sitze und bin immer
ein bisschen stärker am drücken habe ich einen höheren pulz als der kerl beim
start in der rakete und 79 ja
pulz start weiß ich ob es dazu news abbeiträge gibt
er kann ihr müsst ihr müsst das kundes auf jeden fall eine echt nice
dokumentation vielleicht liege ich auf falsches
waren 85 oder so er hatte auf jeden fall einen so niedrigen pulse als ich mir
gedacht habe ich habe beim scheißen einen höheren pulse die anderen hatten
höheren pulse die anderen die anderen beiden höheren pulse aber der typ war
mega entspannt das hat den das hat ihn überhaupt nicht das hat ihn überhaupt
nicht gejuckt hat sich jolo auf der anderen seite ich kann es insofern
verstehen weil du kannst davon ausgehen wenn das ding in die luft fliegt ja
dann wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht mehr allzu viel von mitbekommen
aber es auf jeden fall echt nice doku kann man sich kann man sich angucken hat
auch nicht umsonst so viele gut so viele gute bewährte bewertung und für drei
euro agent war es passt quali ist gut alles original aufnahmen und poggers ja
wie meinst du was
was denn ich meine muss ich mal guckt euch das mal an das ist eine echt gute
quali ne
das waren sind ja kampf und testpiloten ja aber das coole ist dass du den du hast
ihr den vergleich wert
ich denke mal wenn du wenn wenn so eine fette rakete unter deinem arsch
explodiert dass du wirst da nicht mehr allzu viel von mitbekommen von der
explosion
genau die gute die gute quali kommt aus dem schuh wäre auf dem mond nicht
möglich facts die audio qualität ist nicht gut
die haben sie bestimmt ordentlich nach bearbeit dass man alles versteht
übrigens eine sache was auch geil ist also da lernt man auch echt noch ein paar
sachen die haben ja das richtig big brain vorbereitet die hatten
beispielsweise also sie haben ja selbst nicht damit gerechnet so wirklich dass
das klappt dass das das das wird jetzt so verkauft so nach dem motto großer
siegeszug und wir waren uns total sicher und die helden und sonst was aber das
das kommt der dokumentation auch aus die haben ja alle nicht geglaubt also
optimistisch die optimistischen leute haben gesagt also 50 50 realistisch
betrachtet haben da viele gesagt alter das überleben die nicht also welche
mitgearbeitet haben und die hatten für quasi die größt also die die
hauptsächlichen punkte wo was schief gehen kann hatten die schon vorbereitet
reden also der präsident hat schon vorbereitet reden für wenn wenn was
schief geht also sprich wenn die rakete beim start explodiert wäre hatte er
schon eine rede wo er dann irgendwie die heldenhaften amerikaner lobt und so was
der hat schon alles fertig also es war echt absolut massive big brain geplant
das ganze was ich ja so ein bisschen was ich ja so ein bisschen traurig macht wenn
ich so was sehe ist das war 1969 und hättest du mal jemand gefragt 1970
klar mit sicherheit hatten wir es hatten ja auch die rede wenn die nicht mehr
vom mond zurückgekommen werden und hättest du mal jemand gefragt 1970 wie
sieht die welt 2020 aus leute die hätten euch erzählt was weiß ich fliegende
taxis wir sind auf dem maß wir bauen rohstoffe im asteroiden gürtel ab bämb
die hätten dir sonst was erzählt die leute haben damals viel viel mehr die
hatten viel mehr so auf aufbruch stimmungen so auch pro forschung und und
erkundung und sowas da ist ja kaum noch was von übrig geblieben
und heute haben wir nicht mal 50 mb internet bei uns bei jedem haushalt
ja ne fand ich cool also das sieht das merkt man in der docker also es ist es
ist definitiv hat das einen riesen einfluss gehabt auf die damalige zeiten
was die leute so gedacht haben heute heute sind wir mit anderen problemen
heute sind wir mit anderen problemen beschäftigt die ich auch für teilweise
nicht wirklich wir beschäftigen uns mit echt vielen problemen wo man wo man sich
eigentlich so wahnsinnig viel mit beschäftigen müsste aber gut soll sich
lieber um sowas gedanken machen ich bin übrigens mal gespannt ob wir das mit
der mondbasis noch noch erleben die nasa hatte jetzt ein programm ich habe
vergessen wie es heißt roadmap
ja ist das aktuelle nasa programm aber ich habe vergessen wie es heißt hier
das da
artemis artemis genau und die wollen ja quasi glaube am nächsten jahr schon
starten mit versuchen für mondlandung und mondbasis also das heißt ich bin mal
gespannt ob wir das noch erleben also das soll ja laut plan relativ schnell
gehen dass wir eine mondbasis bekommen da bin ich echt mal gespannt und da
schwebt ihn auch unter anderem zu dinger vor wie dass die das dort quasi dann
auf dem mond sachen 3d gedruckt werden soll für neue gebäude und so ganz ganz
abgedrehtes zeug habe ich letzt habe ich letztes video gesehen es war komplett
fail ich habe vergessen wie ist das next die nächsten zehntausend jahre oder so
und das war so bescheuert
was die uns da erzählt haben das war so fail alter
oder war das war das 4000 jahre genau das das war so krass das war so bescheuert
was die sich da für dinger aus den fingern gesaugt haben
ne das meine ich gerade ich mein das da das da das hatte mit der realität überhaupt
nichts zu tun da haben sie da haben sie einem so was erzählt wie sie nach dem
motto 2000 wir können wir können das theoretisch gleich mal gleich mal
gucken das ist wirklich massive pains champ also manche sachen mögen ja sein
aber es ist es wird es wird massiv die haben das massiv überschätzt die
erzählen also dinger 2030 der erste gen manipulierte mensch auf dem maß und
solche abgedrehten dinger wo ich bin im moment moment mein wir reden hier von
neun jahren ja hallo jetzt macht man macht man halb lang ja ok also ich
sollte jetzt an diesen komisch diese komische umfrage machen das machen
jetzt exquisite umfragen also auf geht's time lapse of the future ist das das
oder meinst du ein anderes das ist das oder oder das hier
bin ich mir jetzt gar nicht sicher
ja also ok ich mache erst mal diesen test hier ok der chat der chats mit
erwissen der chat der wartet jetzt ich leute leute wenn ich jetzt ich weiß
genau wenn ich jetzt irgendwas zweideutige sache gibt es erstmal
gleich wieder clips genauso wie die clips wo ich mal gesagt habe bei einer
stellenanzeige aus pass mwd steht für männlich weiß deutsch gleich alles
geklippt geklippt geklippt geklippt doch max guck mal hier gleich wieder voll
aufgeregt also schauen wir mal also ein paar thesen zum wach zum warm werden
exquisite aufwärmung des das war das kann sogar top clip sein ja also wenn
ökonomische globalisierung unausweichlich sollten sie primär
der menschheit dienen anstatt den interessen translation ok die frage ist
mir schon zu kompliziert vor heute abt 3 hat alle was
was ok ok big brain time big brain time
also wenn ökonomische globalisierung unausweichlich ist sollten sie primär
der menschheit dienen anstatt den interessen transnationaler unternehmen ja
wir orientieren uns eh zu wenig am wohlergehen der leute
also ja sehe ich sehe ich so und wisst ihr ich muss jetzt ich muss bei der
sache es mal eine sache sagen weil ich bin ich sicher bin ob ich ob ich so
dieses dieses coronapolitik fazit video machen will das ist immer schwierig wenn
ich mich zu solchen themen äußere auf youtube ich mache ja sowas normalerweise
gar nicht eine sache die ich echt nicht gut finde hat mit corona nur am rande
was zu tun ist das durch das verhalten unserer
anführer aktuell dass dazu führt dass die leute noch weniger vertrauen haben
in politik und dass deswegen noch mehr quasi diese es macht keiner was für mich
ich muss egoistisch sein sich durchsetzt das sage ich ja auch immer das sage ich
aber ich habe anführer gesagt ja wir würden wir okay wir würden wir würdet ihr es wie wir wir
würdet ihr denn sonst nehmen politische vorstände politische vertreter wie auch
immer nennst nennst nennst wie ihr wollt
so prima da sind das sind das sind die anderen oder
ja und vor allem auch in dem bezug dass auf der einen seite gesagt wird
die leute müssen sich jetzt zusammen zusammenreißen und die leute müssen jetzt
mal kürzer treten und und die leute sollen sich nicht mehr treffen und sonst wie das hat
ja alles durchaus seinen sinn das ist ja das ist ja tatsächlich objektiv gesehen auch richtig
das problem dabei ist nur dass das erstens von leuten kommt die komplett ausgesorgt haben die
sich auch keine gedanken darüber machen müssen dass es ihnen jemals irgendwie schlecht gehen
wird unter anderem von der kohle die wir alles samt da täglich oder monatlich bezahlen und dass
man parallel noch häuschen für millionen verkauft und solche geschichten also quasi oder irgendwelche
masken deals macht oder sonstige geschichten quasi in zeiten wo man quasi den leuten vormittag sagt
reißt euch mal zusammen und gibt euch mal alle mühe und dann am nachmittag quasi guckt dass
man möglichst maximal eigenen profit raus draus schlägt ja und wo planen exakt das denke ich
mir auch wie willst du es geht ja noch nicht mal darum wenn leute wenn leute kritisch sind ja also
leute die wirklich skeptisch sind die kann man eh schwer überzeugen aber durch diese ganze geschichte
ist es sogar eher so und auch durch das viele hin und her erst mit impfstoff nur an leute unter
60 dann nur an frauen dann nur an leute über 60 dadurch dass man sich ordentlich erklärt machst
du dir auch impf skeptiker und impfgegner es wird immer so hingestellt als ist das einzeln
schuld der leute weil sie zu dumm sind ist es zum teil mit sicher mit sicherheit auch aber es ist
ein meiner einzig eine hauptaufgabe unserer politischen führungsriege das alles ordentlich
zu vermitteln und auch unterschiedliche interessen zu beachten anstatt ihre eigenen also anstatt
hauptsächlich ihre eigenen und was wozu das führen wird unterm strich ist das nach der nach
dem korona rum ist und das wird eine ganze weile nach korona noch weitergehen die leute haben jetzt
schon prinzipiell kein vertrauen mehr da rein in die entscheidung und da wird es auch nicht besser
dadurch dass man erst sagt masken bringen nichts und nachher kommt raus natürlich bringen masken
was aber man wollte quasi sicherstellen dass die wichtigen stellen was bekommen ehrenwertes ziel
aber letztendlich hat mich noch nicht die wahrheit erzählt da macht es auch nicht besser dass die
korona erfassung wo man wo man war dann obwohl man es vorher anders gesagt hat der polizei zugänglich
gemacht und gemacht wird das mag ja alles ehrenwerte ziele haben man möchte damit vielleicht
wirklich was sinnvolles erreichen aber du kannst nicht heute das sagen und morgen was anderes machen
und dann noch glauben oder oder denken dass die leute dir neue sachen die du sagst auch direkt
abkaufen das ergibt keinen sinn ja und dann noch die kombination dass von versprochenen korona
hilfen kaum was ankommt bei sagen wir mal plakativ der pizzeria um die ecke aber dass du bei größeren
autokonzern explizite abteilungen hast die nichts anderes machen die gucken wie man die sachen
möglichst gut formulieren kann möglichst gut verkaufen kann möglichst gut so hin drehen kann
dass man millionen korona hilfen bekommt das das kannst du so den leuten nicht wirklich vermitteln
und deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass nach der korona krise das vertrauen quasi in in die
politischen skills und und ja politische führung noch viel viel schlechter sein wird als es das
vorher schon war was dann zwar zur oder jetzt auch schon zur folge hat dass da leute unter anderem
anfangen sich irgendwelche verschwörungstheorien sich anzugucken und sagen ja das ist geil dass
leute anfangen irgendwelche extremen sachen zu machen zu denken und eventuell auch zu machen dass
sie keinen bock mehr auf die das ist halt es ist nicht immer nur das weil die leute zu dumm sind
ihr wisst ich halte prinzipiell ja auch also mir geht 99 prozent der menschheit auf den sack und
ich ich merke auch immer drüber rum wie blöd alle leute sind sogar über mich selbst aber man kann
es nicht immer den leuten selbst in die schuhe schieben dass sie dass sie das alles nicht verstehen
würden oder zu dumm sind oder so vieles ist auch eine frage dessen wie vermittelt man es den leuten
und man muss sich einfach nicht wundern wenn man den wenn man die menschen an lügt am stück dass
sie dann irgendwann sagen glaube ich nicht ja ja und man hätte sicherlich die ein oder andere
leute die heute auf wegen der querdenken demo sind im vorfeld hätte man die leute anders
behandelt wenn die wahrscheinlich nie da bin ich mir sehr sicher das kommt jacky das kommt auch
noch dabei wenn du eh schon ein bisschen da nicht so genau weiß und wenn du wenn du eh schon nicht
so gefestigt bist ja ich weiß nicht wie ich jetzt nennen soll oder wenn oder oder wenn du eh schon so leicht
zweifel hast dass das alles gut gemanagt ist und dann kommt noch so was und dann hast du einfach
komplettes vertrauen verloren naja ja also wie gesagt denke ich auch denke ja ja ja genau ja
natürlich genau das genau das wird ja auch passieren ich sage ja auch dass sagen wir mal
ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr afd bashing betreiben ihr wisst ich ich versuche sowas meistens wenig mit
in irgendwelche richtungen da sinnlos zu bashen aber ich gehe davon aus dass ein relativ großer
teil der leute die afd wählen gar nicht wegen der afd die könnten eigentlich machen was sie
wollen denen ist es wahrscheinlich scheiß egal die wollen aber auf gar keinen fall das mehr wählen
was sie die letzten jahre enttäuscht hat und dann sagen sie sich hey ich wähle jetzt einfach mal
was komplett anderes was was kommt quasi quasi so komplett dagegen ist eventuell auch vielleicht
sogar gegen sachen wo die leute tatsächlich früher selbst mal dagegen waren oder sagen das
passt überhaupt nicht die sagen sich hey es gibt zwar einige differenzen ich ich finde das nicht
gut aber ich finde das immer noch besser als das was etablierte machen und da kommen ganz viele
leute auf von von dieser von dieser von dieser richtung da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher und ich
weiß gar nicht ob es dazu irgendwelche umfragen gibt wird mich echt mal interessieren aber ich
könnte mir echt vorstellen dass viele leute die heute die afd wählen enttäuschte cdu csu
sonst was wähler sind und das hätte man also das ist gar nicht so sehr der verdienst der afd dass
die immer mehr wähler bekommt oder hat jetzt ja glücklicherweise ein bisschen weniger gekriegt
aber sondern auch zum großen teil weil es die letzten jahre total versäumt wurde gewisse
gewisse leute zu beachten oder ihre probleme ernst zu nehmen da musst du dich nicht wundern
näher haben sie ja sie haben gesehen dass die parteien die sie per die sie die letzten jahre
über gewählt haben sie nur enttäuscht haben zehn jahre lang dann sagen die sich juckt mich
nett dann wähle ich jetzt das andere extreme gut ist das kann ich nachvollziehen man kann
als viel hin und her darüber diskutieren ob das blöd ist oder nicht aber es ist auch ein ganz
großer teil das versagen derjenigen die die leute letzten jahre unterstützt haben
also ich denke mal gerade cdu wähler werden da relativ viele hingeflitzt sein die letzten
jahre über wobei man halt auch mal fernes halber sagen muss ich habe mir mal ein paar ich habe
mir mal ein paar reden angehört gibt es ja auf youtube mittlerweile alles man muss sagen hey
es haben das muss man echt der fernes halber jetzt auch mal sagen es haben echt alle viele
dummschwetzer am start ja und die ein oder anderen reden die ich gehört habe von leute
von der afd war auch nicht alle total beknackt also es ist halt wie immer nicht die welt nicht
schwarz und weiß du hast nicht auf der einen seite 100 prozentig schwach sind auf der anderen
seite 100 prozentig gutes muss halt immer gucken ok was ist so die sache die irgendwie
noch so am ehesten wenn ich glück habe das macht was man will das ist ja auch das blöde
und ich ich könnte mir ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen wenn es mal wirklich eine partei
gäbe wenn es wenn es mal wirklich eine partei gäbe die ernsthaft einen zukunftsplan hätte
und auch ein paar charismatische leute die quasi auch auch ein programm verdreht mit
dem sich wirklich viele leute identifizieren können die hätten echte chancen ja das hat
das hast du auch ja es gibt halt es gibt immer weniger leute die in der mitte neutral platziert
sind du hast welche das siehst du auf twitter du hast ganz viele in die eine richtung und
ganz viele in die andere richtung ich werde mit euch es gibt leute die gehen auf die barrikaden
auf twitter wenn ich sagen würde hey nicht 100 prozent der sachen die die afd sagt sind
schwach sind es ist eigentlich eine ganz normale aussage weil nicht so gut wie gar nichts es
gibt es gibt fast nichts was 100 prozent ist ja ist die erde rund ja relativ sicher aber
nicht 100 prozent und sie ist bei der weihe auch nicht rund die ist eher so oval da sind
der wenn die leute schon ultra triggert das das stimmt das stimmt das stimmt das ist
genau das umgedrehte extrem hast du auch wenn du dann leute hast die der meinungen sind
nur weil einer ein bisschen bisschen sozialer eingestellt ist oder vielleicht für umweltschutz
sich einsetzt oder sonst sonst was auch immer dass das gleich ein ein was gibt es dann links
grün versiffter gutmensch ist du kannst wunderbar die leute in irgendwelche schuppler anstecken
und sagen jawoll das das ist so und so ist er und jetzt weiß ich alles über den nachdem
du einen satz gehört hast bringt halt nur im endeffekt nix das wird einfach auch der
komplexität der situation überhaupt nicht gerecht also es werden viele sachen immer
so so debatten wenn es die überhaupt gibt so total platt geführt die die die realität
ist halt nun mal relativ komplex und das kannst du halt somit ich weiß nach einem satz alles
über dich und du bist jetzt das oder du bist das oder bis das geht halt nicht ja das glaube
ich tatsächlich auch und ich gehe mal davon aus eines der besten sachen die die afd theoretisch
machen könnte wäre mit den mit dem teil der leute die nicht total da rad ab haben eine
neue partei zu gründen irgendwas weil dem ganzen laden haftet halt schon denn doch recht
wie soll man sagen unwählbarer und negativer ruf an natürlich gibt es noch extremere die
man man kann auch wie gibt es noch gibt sie npd noch ja also gibt es sicherlich auch
leute die sagen er ist mir nicht krass genug ich will die npd ich muss euch sagen ich finde
das system dieses in den gibt sie noch ok also ich muss sagen ich finde das system wie
es in den usa ist von den parteien her gar nicht mal so durf du hast in den usa ja im
endeffekt nur zwei parteien weil der dort jammer dieses jammer dieses komisches system
mit ihren wahlmännern das heißt wenn ein gewinner in einem in einem bundesstaat feststeht
dann wählen alle wahlmänner den gewinner also nicht anteilmäßig also nicht anteilmäßig
wie die in den bundesstaat gewählt haben sondern die wählen immer den der gewonnen
hat mit allen stimmen ich finde das gar nicht so doof ich finde das system gar nicht mal
so blöd und auch das mit den zwei parteien ist gar nicht so doof und zwar das hat zur
folge dass naja das ist du hast immer sagen die sind nicht ganz optimal ja bei uns ja
nur wirklich auch nicht ich mein du hast beispielsweise nicht wirklich du kannst auch keinen bundeskanzler
direkt wählen oder kannst du die kannst du nicht du kannst du willst die partei also
warum ich das ansofern gar nicht mal ganz schlecht finde ist ein vorteil von der ganzen
geschichte in den usa ja gut das ist das ist ein anderes problem es geht aber um die grundsätzliche
geschichte also das gute daran ist wenn du zwei parteien hast warum kriegst du dich auf
was gibt es denn zum aufregen also warum ich das an sich nicht schlecht finde ist du hast
dadurch einen vorteil du hast immer eine gegenstimme die auch rückhalt hat also sprich die haben
immer eine opposition opposition am start die auch nennen wir es mal gefährlich ist
das hast du hier nicht unbedingt also so schlecht finde ich das vom ansatz her gar nicht
ja es hat alles eine vornachtrei aber deswegen ist ja das prinzip an sich nicht schlecht
oder nicht gleich total für den arsch sicherlich gibt es da bestimmt ein paar sachen die nicht
ganz fair sind aber nur weil nun paar sachen finde es die von dem gesamten konstrukt vielleicht
nicht 100 prozentig toll sind heißt ja nicht dass das instant alles totaler bullshit ist
und das finde ich von der idee her gar nicht so übel dass du immer eine opposition automatisch
am start hast die rückendeckung hat irgendwer und die auch gefährlich ist also die das
finde ich beim system bei den amis gar nicht so doof
es wäre ja noch blöder wenn du einfach komplett machen kannst was du willst also ich bin
mal gespannt wie das bei uns im oktober wird die umfragewerte sehen ja gerade nicht so
gut aus für die tdu die sind ja gerade nicht so geil aber haben wir hier irgendwas
außerdem wenn man sich noch mal ganz wenn man sich zu der sache den usa beschwert wenigstens
es ist für alle gleich ja klar du hast starten die tendieren eher dazu das zu wählen andere
eher das aber wenigstens die voraussetzungen ja man prinzipiell rechtlich gesehen für
alle beteiligten gleich also sprich es ist jetzt nicht so dass es in bundes bundesstaat
irgendwie so und so viel prozent wählen müssen irgendwie also das
aber dazu muss ich sagen außer mit so der mit dem grundsätzlichen ablauf ich kenne
mich mit innenpolitischen sachen in usa absolut nicht aus ich finde den ansatz mit zwei parteien
und dass du einer am start hast die halt immer so gefährlich ist und und beträchtlichen
teil der bevölkerung hinter sich hat nicht verkehrt so also sonntags umfrage was zum
teufel habe ich da auf what the fuck kantar was was zum wo ist kantar das hört sich an
wie in dubai oder so was zum ach nee das ist die typen die die umfragen gemacht haben
oder was ach das ist ein institut ok zeig mal her ja das sieht alles schonmal ungefähr
gleich aus gibt es da gibt es auch irgendwie mal eine gescheite side sowas da zum beispiel
oder so ja das sagt doch alles gibt es ja nicht umfragen und prognosen hier excellent
wikipedia wikipedia wikipedia weiß mal wieder besser bescheid wikipedia machts machts besser
als die offizielle seite also um aktuelle umfrage so forza die forza umfrage die sagt
also die grüne haben echt heftig zugelegt ne lull sogar die spd also das sind die letzten
die ich haben will dann hast du die ftp kriegt auch wieder mehr die afd ein bisschen weniger
die linke sind so ja so im prinzip so wie immer die brauche ich aber ehrlich gesagt
auch da nicht also ich ich lieb euch ja immer noch so ein bisschen mit der ftp allerdings
dann auch wiederum nicht so genau aber die grüne haben krass zugelegt können euch noch
dran erinnern beim letzten mal wo europa europawahl war wo alle gesagt haben ja dass die grüne
da jetzt so viel zugelegt haben das ist so eine so eine temporäre erscheinung die wird
garantiert nicht wird sich garantiert nicht soweit durchsetzen also das das sieht anders
aus ja wenn das so weitergeht also wenn das so weitergeht und die cdu csu das noch ein
bisschen coronamäßig verscheißt dann müssen die sich vielleicht mal sogar mal Gedanken
um kanzlerkandidaten machen haben die denn da überhaupt irgendein also ich meine gut
mir fällt jetzt eh allgemein keiner ein warum ich mich drüber freuen würde aber gut sei
mal dahingestellt der test okay wir machen jetzt den test exquisite also ich mach jetzt
den test auf geht's komm bevor ich jetzt ewig lang rum mache also auf geht's so zustimmung
ich würde immer mein land unterstützen egal ob es richtig oder falsch handelt nö warum
nicht wenn wenn man scheiße baut muss man das auch benennen dürfen ich muss ich bei
jedem scheiß mitmachen der mir gefällt na ups beispielsweise finde ich gez gebühren
beziehungsweise zwangseintreibung wie sie das aktuell machen auch scheiße kann ich
auch sagen so auch wenn ich den kram bezahle niemand sucht sich seinen geburtstand aus
da ist es ein mann darauf stolz zu sein ich ganz ehrlich ich würde das jedem selbst zugestehen
worauf er stolz sein will wenn einer darauf stolz sein will dass er in was auch immer
in simbapwe oder wo auch immer geboren ist kann er das machen ähm auf der anderen seite
ich würde da gar nicht mal unbedingt zustimmen ähm weil wenn jetzt jemand sagt ich finde
es cool äh keine ahnung deutscher zu sein schweizer zu sein franzose zu sein und sagt
dann irgendwie was weiß ich ganz viele erfinder waren irgendwie deutsch und französisch oder
irgendwie mein mein super vorbild ist auch irgendwie in italien und ich bin froh italienisch
zu sein warum nicht ja warum nicht daher ist es allwann darauf stolz zu sein ja nö also
ich würde sagen die leute können da schon drauf stolz sein wenn sie Spaß machen kann
es dir halt nix von kaufen letztendlich ne also es ist relativ sinnlos da drauf stolz
zu sein aber hey kann man machen ja man könnte auch zum beispiel sagen ähm was weiß ich
mein opa und meine oma haben dafür gesorgt dass es uns heute so gut geht natürlich bin
ich da stolz drauf und sowas ähm also deswegen würde ich nicht ich würde da nicht prinzipiell
zustimmen zu sagen es ist es ist doof wenn man darauf stolz ist so also im vergleich
zu anderen rassen hat unsere rasse viel überlegt ok das ist die nazifrage das ist eindeutig
die nazifrage da weißt du bescheid ok jetzt musst du gucken dass sich nicht die wie rum
die gestellt ist im vergleich zu einer rasse an unserer rasse viele überlegene eigenschaften
es gibt da sogar auch zig studien zu dass es zum größten teil auf das soziale umfeld
und sachen aufkommt wo jemand aufwächst dass es sonst eigentlich außer der optik und vielleicht
der gachi basslänge nicht so viele unterschiede gibt ist die deutsche version gut übersetzt
also man kann auch deutlich ablehnen ja dann lehne ich deutlich ab der feind meines feindes
ist mein freund das kommt auf die situation an das kommt auf die situation an keine ahnung
ich habe militäreinsätze die gegen internationales recht verschoben sind noch noch mal was sind
manchmal gerecht vielleicht nein also irgendwelche komischen dinger machen wie die usa teilweise
wo es ja auch sehr fragwürdig ist was damit manchen drohen abgeknallt wird ich finde es
übrigens auch nicht gut dass wir uns an einigen sachen da beteiligen du musst die frage machen
sonst geht es nicht mehr ist ich wenn ich die frage machen muss dann keine keine ahnung
was soll ich dazu sagen ich habe keinen schimmer es gibt im moment eine bedenkliche verbindung
der information und was es gibt im moment eine bedenkliche verbindung der informations
und unterhaltungsindustrie was also leute entweder bin ich dazu 3 hat für oder ich
verstehe es nicht es gibt im moment eine bedenkliche verbindung der informations und unterhaltungsindustrie
die meinen die meinen quasi ja aber wo ist denn da der unterschied ich meine meinen die
meinen noch ein fernsehsender fernsehsender bei uns sollte unterhalten und information
machen oder wie oder was achso die meinen dass sie quasi eigentlich objektiv informieren
sollten und da keine agenda oder wie auch immer dahinter ist oder wie das kam es schlecht
also die frage ist doof gestellt also dass im film serien ein gewisses narrativ verdrehen
da würde ich sogar zustimmen also wie neutral fernsehberichte sind habe ich so meine zweifel
und gerade in zeiten von clickbait neigt man dazu die sachen in bestimmtes licht zu rücken
einfach dass es mehr zuschauer generiert also da würde ich sogar ich weiß nicht ob
ich das damit habe ich sogar ein bisschen zustimmen ok nächste seite
oh profix die deine der automata deine nachricht geblockt weil alles wurde schwuler drin vorgekommen
ist mocha tos ja also menschen sind letztendlich eher wegen ihrer klasse gespannt als wegen
ihrer national was zum teufel was für eine klasse alles ist ein mmo ich bin klarig du
bist tank ich bin dd was zum teufel ist eine klasse gesellschaftlicher ran dann sollte
man vielleicht ran wegen jetzt wegen ihres wohlstandes gesellschaftlicher anecke was
auch immer ok wenn man das mal mit sozialer schicht übersetzt als wegen ihrer nation naja
es kommt drauf an es gibt durchaus die fragen sind ein bisschen pepega es gibt durchaus
nationalitäten die können sich absolut nicht ab selbst wenn die in der gleichen klasse
sind ja das ist schwierig also aber gut beziehen wir das mal auf unsere sache hier also ich
denke schon dass es tatsächlich die ein oder andere gibt die sich rein wegen ihrer nationalität
nicht abkönnen aber das ist denke ich mal tatsächlich nicht die mehrheit die meisten
leute können sich wegen anderer gründe nicht ab und die die wenn man mal von klassen ausgeht
vieles wird ja auch geschickt gegeneinander ausgespielt um irgendwelche diskussionen vom
zahn zu brechen ja da werden arme leute was weiß ich du hast du hast 4 empfänger du hast
arbeitslose du hast 4 empfänger du hast leute die irgendwelche 400 euro jobs machen was
auch immer die werden dann gegeneinander ausgespielt insofern dass gesagt wird hey der eine arbeitet
mehr warum bekommt er dann weniger als du und hin und her da werden die leute ein bisschen
gegeneinander ausgespielt und ich glaube das ist eines der größten probleme und was dazu
geführt dass mittlerweile wir ja auch zu einem der länder gehören wo die schere zwischen
arm und reich jetzt auch glaube ich auch top 5 oder so jetzt sind relativ weit oben und
aber auch erst sein aber auch noch nicht ewig also es ist es ist noch das ist noch nicht
so lange her dass wir dann oberen rennen mitspielen und das ist auch denke ich ein relativ großes
problem in der richtung also sagen wir mal ich stimme da eher zu auch wenn ich genau
weiß was die wollen also die inflation zu steuern ist wichtiger als die arbeitslose
alter mein die inflation zu steuern ist wichtiger als die arbeitslosigkeit zu steuern schwer
zu sagen ich würde ja fast behaupten mit ordentlicher wirtschaftspolitik gäbe es da
nicht so viel was man direkt steuern müsste ich bleibe da mal auf ablehnung so weil man
nicht darauf vertrauen kann das unternehmen freiwillig die umwelt schützen muss man sie
schärfer regulieren nein ich bin überhaupt nicht dafür dass unter unternehmen noch stärker
reguliert werden wir haben so viele vorschriften wir haben so viele vorschriften das ist es
ist teilweise so unattraktiv in deutschland irgendwas zu machen das ist der wahnsinn
habe ich das falsch verstanden weil man weil man nicht darauf vertrauen kann dass unternehmen
freiwillig die umwelt schützen muss man sie ja nee man sollte nicht stärker kontrollieren
natürlich es ist der chat das ist ein ganz entscheidender denkfehler den meiner meinung
nach viele leute machen ein ganz entscheidender denkfehler das heißt nicht dass die umwelt
egal ist das heißt nicht dass die umwelt egal ist das ist die frage wie man das macht also
sprich wenn man wenn man sagt hey es ist vielleicht nicht sinnvoll die unternehmen noch stärker
zu regulieren heißt es nicht automatisch dass man für umweltverschmutzung ist zum beispiel
könnte man auch sagen hey warum sorgen wir nicht dafür na gut wir haben also wir haben
in deutschland schon regularien und mass für für unternehmen ja dass man hey dass es
dass es vielleicht die ein oder anderen gibt die bei der regulierung oder bei den regeln
die angewendet werden ein bisschen gleicher als andere sind sei mal dahingestellt das
sind aber unterschiedliche probleme aber ich bin der meinung man sollte eher gucken dass
man das ganze auf einer auf einem ordentlichen fundament hat und ein ordentliches fundament
schafft man meiner meinung nach nicht dadurch dass man alles wie wild reguliert sondern
dass man zum beispiel dafür sorgt dass umweltfreundliche technologien eben zukunftsfähig sind du kannst
es den leuten du kannst es den leuten doch aber auch gar nicht vermitteln guck mal zum
beispiel bei der bei der einfachen frage wenn es um öffentliche verkehrsmittel geht wo
ist der sinn zu verbieten mit autos in innenstädten zu fahren doch die unternehmen müssen die
müssen ein ordentliches fundament legen beispielsweise siehst du das gerade beim trend von elektroautos
wenn sie das nicht machen sind sie weg vom fenster ganz einfach aber man sieht doch man
sieht zum beispiel schon bei öffentlichem nachverkehr es ist doch überhaupt nicht sinnvoll
zu sagen man verbietet den leuten mit dem auto in die innenstadt zu fahren
wie soll das funktionieren
das ergibt doch keinen sinn du musst den leuten alternative bieten die praktikabel
sind dann machen die leute das also wenn du sagst die leute dürfen nicht in in die stadt
mehr fahren oder die leute gerade die dies brauchen um auf die arbeit zu kommen dürfen
nur noch mit mit super neuen super teuren umweltfreundlichen autos in die stadt fahren
dann wirst du dafür sorgen dass manche leute schlicht und kraft nicht mehr arbeiten können
du musst dann in dem fall dafür sorgen dass öffentliche verkehrsmittel eine zuverlässige
bezahlbare alternative sind was meinst du wie viele leute dann freiwillig aufs auto
verzichten werden du kannst das schlecht erzwingen du kannst so was unglaublich schlecht erzwingen
das nächste ist zum beispiel sollte man sollte man ganz viel geld rein stecken quasi um
aktuelle technologien flächen das ist jetzt eine frage das habe ich keine antwort drauf
ja um aktuelle technologien auszubauen sollte also es gibt ja zwei grundsätzliche unterschiedliche
ansätze die man fahren kann zum beispiel zu sagen hey wir nehmen das was jetzt da ist
sagen wir den aktuellen stand von von von china solar panels von windkraftanlagen von
wasser und sonst wie und nehmen unser geld und stecken das da rein um quasi infrastruktur
mit aktueller technik hinzustellen oder versuchen mit der kohle zur technologie in der zukunft
zu entwickeln das sind so zwei komplett unterschiedliche ansätze die man fahren kann ich das kann jetzt
keiner von uns wirklich sagen was da besser und schlechter ist das wird man wahrscheinlich
das müssen zukünftige generationen wahrscheinlich dann entscheiden aber ich finde mehr regulierung
die wir die wir eh schon also wir haben ja schon verdammt viel regulierung in ganz vielen
ganz vielen richtung finde ich nicht sinnvoll zumal man es jetzt gerade bei der autoindustrie
sucht gerade sieht wenn die nicht mitmachen mit elektroautos dann sind die weg vom fenster
und das haben die mittlerweile selbst gecheckt was meint ihr denn warum die so warum warum
die so attacke machen in der richtung nein rego da bin ich nicht für aber da gibt es
garantiert schon regelungen dass das so ohne weiteres nicht erlaubt ist stärkere regulierung
heißt in der regel immer irgendwelche sachen verbieten oder irgendwelche quoten einführen
oder irgendwelche sachen irgendwelche auflagen machen die entgegen die oftmals entgegen dem
laufen was man eigentlich will regulieren heißt nicht verbieten die meisten der fälle
ist das aber so ja und natürlich muss man braucht braucht gewisse regularien aber wir
haben schon so viel unglaublich vieles zeug ich bin aber wir brauchen nicht mehr ihr müsst
jetzt nicht so an den wort regulieren ich finde ich finde das lustig so bei so einfachen
sachen schon schon übelst abgeht ja was aber witzig ist ja ich argumentiere mit dem was
man oft gesehen hat also wenn ihr dir das mal aktuell anguckst dann werden eigentlich
so gut für alles was stört immer direkt verbote gefordert das heißt das erste was einem da
natürlich in den sinn kommt ist dass dinger verboten werden zum beispiel du darfst mich
näher das war das war noch nicht vor allzu langer zeit im gespräch du darfst nicht
mehr mit deinem auto in die innenstadt fahren das ist ja noch nicht lange her wo das thema
war wir sollten einfach korona verbieten das wäre auch mal was ja und so sachen ergeben
einfach keinen sinn das funktioniert nicht zum beispiel nächste sache mit verbieten guckst
hier in berlin an wir verbieten den leuten ihr eigentum zu dem preis anbieten zu können
zu vermieten was sie wollen es hat auch nicht das bewirkt was man wollte also deswegen
also man sieht ja dass das verbote oftmals das erste ist was einem was einem da so einfällt
also ich bin da man wir haben da erst mal genug und klar muss man und klar muss man regulieren
aber das wichtigste ist dass das im hinblick auf das gemacht wird was auch was auch langfristig
tragbar ist wenn man zum beispiel daran denkt als solare energie auf den dächern gefördert
wurde war eine coole idee war ja an sich eine coole idee letztendlich hat es dafür geführt
dass alle mehr geld für strom bezahlen müssen inklusive denen die eingespeist haben weil
die haben sich quasi selbst bezahlt aber
wie können wir denn genug haben wenn die klimaziele in paris so weit weg sind es gibt immer es
gibt ja immer ein unterschied zwischen dem was da ist und ob man sich dran hält ja bei
diesem ganzen klima abkommen ist es ja so da wird viel beschlossen aber nichts gemacht
oder oftmals wenig noch weniger beschlossen und davon nicht dann nichts gemacht meinst
du ernsthaft mehr mehr mehr punkte in diesem text dokument hätten dazu geführt dass man
sich mehr dran hält also es gibt ja zu vielen sachen schon vorschriften regularien punkte
nehmen irgendwelche nehmen den internetausbau internetausbau wird seit jahrzehnten angekündigt
in zwei jahren haben wir das in zwei jahren haben wir das in zwei jahren haben wir das
passiert auch nix
wenn das nicht wirtschaftlich wird also wenn das nicht wenn du es nicht schaffst das in
irgendeiner art und weise wie auch immer halbwegs erträglich wirtschaftlich zu machen dann
wird es die firmen nicht mehr geben wie soll es denn funktionieren du kannst doch kein
zwingen du musst das du musst das dann wenn schon so teuer machen dass es sich absolut
nicht mehr lohnt und dann sind die leute danach wieder am rumheulen wenn es den bach wenn
es den bach wenn es den bach runtergeht also es ist unglaublich schwierig das unter einen
hut zu bringen aber wie gesagt muss ich muss ich nur hinter das ausbau angucken da wird
auch von einem jahr aufs andere was vorgeschlagen und wird auch wird sich auch nicht dran gehalten
und es gibt klima abkommen und sonstige dinger das ist ja alles schön und gut aber man sieht
immer wieder dass das quasi das papier nicht wert ist auf dem steht das wird unterschrieben
und wird sich einfach gedacht scheißen wir drauf gut die chinesen machen schon mal gar
nicht mit weil die china chinesen sich halt denken wir scheiß drauf aber das ist denen
ja auch klar das ist denen ja auch also die sind ja nicht blöd die sind ja nicht blöd
die chinesen wissen auch dass das ein problem ist und aber dass das die eigentliche problematik
ist ja dass keiner zurückstecken will es wird keiner zurückstecken keiner der beteiligten
die da auch solche dinger unterzeichnet haben sagt ok ich mache das jetzt und und nehme
nachteile für mich in kauf auf der anderen seite muss man sich auch mal überlegen es
wäre ja auch nicht sonderlich clever nachteile für sich in kauf zu nehmen da habe ich letztens
übrigens echt gutes video zu gucken muss ich mal rausholen ob ich das finde weil überlegt
euch mal also mal genommen fünf länder fünf länder machen ein klima abkommen und vier
länder halten sich nicht dran denen geht es wirtschaftlich dann ganz gut ein land sagt
ich halte mich eisern dran ja ich schränke mich ein ich mache weniger ich gebe verdammt
viel geld aus ja und den geht es danach schlecht die werden quasi mit der zeit arm meint ihr
einer der vier anderen länder würde das jemals nachmachen die nachbarländer sagen ja gut
dass wir es nicht gemacht haben da können wir von ausgehen die nachbarländer mit sagen
wir haben glück gehabt dass wir uns da nicht dran gehalten haben die werden da nicht nach
und die werden das nie im leben werden die da mitziehen und deswegen kannst du im endeffekt
mit wir machen uns arm die leute nicht überzeugen können wo widerspreche ich mir denn da selbst
das ist im prinzip das was ich sage du kannst es nicht du kannst es nicht mit mit erzwingen
machen und in der hoffnung es macht dann dir einer nach das funktioniert nicht du musst
gucken dass du das so managt wie auch immer ich bin kein wirtschaftsexperte deswegen kann
ich dazu nichts sagen du musst schauen dass du das so managt dass es ein vorbild ist für
andere länder sie sagen auch guck mal die haben das so gut hinbekommen und denen geht
es gut dabei das können wir nachmachen können wir nächste frage mal ja zeilen danke für
den primes ab ja ja wir machen die nächste frage ist gut exquisite ja das ist richtig
deswegen ist der einzige weg wie du das schaffen kannst dass andere länder mitmachen indem
du zeigst guck mal wir können es wir können wir können das schaffen umweltfreundlich
zu sein oder umweltfreundlicher zu sein und uns geht es damit trotzdem gut ok nächste
frage nächste frage man jeder was jeder nach seinen fähigkeiten jeden nach seinen bedürfnissen
ist grundsätzlich eine gute idee alter was sind das für fragen könnt ihr nicht könnt
ihr nicht irgendwas ein bisschen klarer formuliert das nehmen ist das nicht gekonnt ist das
nicht gekommetet frage ist das china china frage
jeder nach seinen fähigkeiten jedem nach seinen bedürfnissen
ich habe keine ahnung was uns das sagen soll also sprich jeder sollte das machen was er
kann und jeder sollte das bekommen was er braucht oder wie klingt ja erst mal gut ich
habe keine ahnung was sie uns damit genau sagen wollen je freier der markt desto freier
die menschen da würde ich prinzipiell zustimmen es ist ein armutszeugnis für unsere gesellschaft
das etwas grundlegendes wie trinkwasser nun ein in flaschen ab abgefülltes produkt ist
so warum also bei der way mein trinkwasser ist nicht in flaschen abgefüllt ich habe
einen sodasprudler und ich trinke echtes hanauer leitungswasser ist das ein armuts
warum den hintergrund verstehe ich jetzt nicht warum sollte man kein leitungswasser verkaufen
dürfen ich darf ich darf auch open source software von github runterladen und auf usb
sticks verkaufen wenn ich einen finde das kauft land sollte keine wahre sein die man
kaufen oder verkaufen kann warum also ich bin froh dass ich ein grundstück habe land
auch sollte keine wahre sein ne land darf man grundstück und so kann man doch kaufen
und verkaufen ist doch alles in ordnung es ist bedauerlich dass menschen persönliche
reichtümer anhäufen können indem sie einfach geld machen ich bin nicht zu ihnen gesagt
das ist jetzt mal eine äußerst pauschale äußerst pauschale aussage ja indem sie einfach
geld machen was soll denn das jetzt bedeuten ist das so was in der richtung wie jemand
der ist das quasi jemand wie wall street bats oder was im endeffekt
also mit dem mit der ersten hälfte habe ich überhaupt keine überhaupt keine schmerzen
das ist absolut in ordnung dass leute persönliche reichtümer anhäufen können indem sie einfach
geld manipulieren zu ihrer gesellschaft das ist wiederum die frage machen sie das wirklich
also ich habe da ich habe also ich habe keine probleme mit wenn einer geld mit stonks macht
überhaupt nicht und ich habe auch keine probleme mit der ganzen wall street bettgeschichte
das ist bedauerlich dass menschen persönliche reichtümer ja ob sie nicht zur gesellschaftsbeitragung
sei mal dahingestellt weiß ich nicht aber nachdem also der ersten hälfte würde ich
komplett würde ich komplett widersprechen also ich würde ich würde der ganzen sache
tatsächlich eher ich würde die sache eher eher nicht zustimmen das ist aber schwer
jetzt ja protektions ist es für den handel manchmal notwendig ok wir müssen erst mal
google ich bin zu three hat für was ist das aha ach das ist amerika first oder was ist
eine form der handelspolitik mit der einen start durch handelshemmnisse eier ok exzellent
Exzellent das ist das ist Kokona first ok und und China first und so also
Es mag jetzt widersprüchlich klingen
Ich ich war ja so pro freier Wirtschaft und allem in den letzten Fragen
Wobei da würde ich tatsächlich sagen
Es kommt auf den fall an also ich finde es zum beispiel nicht sonderlich sinnvoll
Wenn die chinesen zu viel geld haben und bei uns irgendwelche firmen kaufen in in der masse
Die china chinesen und umgedreht sind die chinesen da auch ganz fett mit dabei
Also das ist das ist an sich allerdings ist jetzt aber auch die andere sache nicht wirklich gut ja
Ich würde tatsächlich zustimmen dass es dass es sicherlich manchmal fälle gibt da ist ein bisschen
genauer drauf schauen nicht verkehrt wir kaufen aber auch ausländische firmen damit habe ich
kein problem können wir machen ich will bloß nicht dass die chinesen uns kaufen es ist mir
wurscht die einzige soziale verantwortung ist das sein anteils nein das sehe ich nicht so
das sehe ich nicht so das würde ich als ultra big strong man der sonst nichts anderes macht
vielleicht zu sehen sollte es zumindest nicht sein weil wenn das wird wenn das passiert dann
verkommen quasi alle leuten im endeffekt zu zu ressourcen und das finde ich nicht gut reiche
menschen werden zu hoch besteuert tja also ihr kennt meine meinung zu der geschichte mich
fackt ab dass ich spitzensteuersatz bezahlen muss ja 42 prozent und also ist aktuell das
spitzen nicht der schmitzer spitzensteuersatz 20 72 42 prozent ab wann ist man reich definiere
reich definiere reich das problem ist gar nicht mal so sehr die nein nein ich glaube
es sind 42 prozent das problem ist gar nicht mal so sehr dass das die steuersätze da nicht
hoch genug werden sondern die möglichkeiten reiche also richtig reiche leute haben deutlich
mehr möglichkeiten sich da mittel und wege zu suchen eben nicht so viel zu bezahlen und
sei es nur dass die firma in luxemburg ist oder so also wenn die damit meinen mit dieser
frage ich soll mehr steuern bezahlen dann bin ich definitiv dagegen
also im zweifelsfall weil ich eher dagegen sonst wird es natürlich mehr geld bezahlen
muss ne hör mal auf mir geht schon auf den sack dass ich dass ich spitzensteuersatz bezahlen
muss und irgendwie in meinem interesse damit gemacht wird ja es gibt leider keine hier
in dem fall definition von reich ja mach mal mehr deutliche antwortung bis zu zentral
ja so bin ich halt also diejenigen die es sich leisten können haben das recht bessere
medizinische versorgung zu behalten zu erhalten ja da also ja haben sie aber das niveau das
niveau mit dem die allgemeinheit versorgt werden sollte sollte höher sein was wie nein
heute das ist doch komplett utopisch wenn du 50 millionen hast und zum spitzenarzt nach
südindien fliegen kannst und ich dort für 150.000 euro behandeln lassen kannst beim
ex beim besten spezialist der welt dass das nichts ist was irgendwie für die allgemeinheit
erschwinglich ist ja also und ja natürlich du kannst den leuten das recht nicht nehmen
sich mit geld was zu kaufen also also wie willst du das machen ja und ich finde es
auch nicht gut dass wir eine zwei klassen medizin haben habe ich habe ich auch schon
öfter genug die stories erzählt deswegen bezahle ich ja auch ab und zu jetzt mittlerweile
sachen freiwillig privat ich finde ich gut wie das ist du kannst den leuten aber das
ja auch nicht irgendwie dass das das das nee also da müsstest du ja quasi wie soll man
sagen freie verträge nicht erlauben zwischen zwischen zwischen ärzten und leuten ja also
klar also wenn du geld hast kannst du dir immer bessere medizinische versorgung bezahlen
nicht dass du trotz finde ich dass die versorgung die man normalerweise so bekommt zu schlecht
ist und immer schlechter wird muss ich mal überlegen wenn du hier zum arzt gehst du
bist du bist kassenversichert der hat der guckt dich dreieinhalb minuten an und schickt
dich wieder heim ist jetzt mal so übertrieben zu sagen wenn du dahin gehst und sag ich bezahle
selbst bist du nicht nur in der viertel stunde dran also inklusive anruf und ich komme jetzt
vorbei sondern du wirst auch eine viertel stunde untersucht wie gesagt ich war mit meiner
mutter wegen wegen der hüfte privat privat beim beim arzt in frankfurt und wir waren
zweimal da und er hat insgesamt 45 minuten untersucht und gemacht das wäre gesetzlich
versichert absolut nicht vorstellbar gewesen und das finde ich kacke dass das so ein riesen
unterschied ist allerdings die die möglichkeit dazu sich bessere versorgung zu kaufen die
die wird da kannst du nichts dagegen machen ja wenn ich das geld habe und kann sagen
hey ich gehe zum ich gehe zum super spezialist für krankheit xy da kann sie die leute nicht
absprechen ich weiß war das ist scheiße das ist wirklich kacke wie das gerade ist
also wie gesagt das recht haben sie und das wirst du nichts dagegen dagegen machen können
aber nicht dass du trotz muss die versorgung der bevölkerung besser sein als sie jetzt
ist ja was willst du was willst du denn dagegen machen du kannst doch den leuten nicht verbieten
mit einem spezialist sich von einem spezialist behandeln zu lassen der 150.000 euro kostet
mit mit alle möglichen drum und dran die die die versorgung der bevölkerung sollte doch
bestmöglich sein das ist nicht das ist geld technisch nicht machbar die versorgung der
bevölkerung sollte sollte so sein dass man gut behandelt wird aber nicht erstklassig
du kannst komplette erstklassige auf weltklasse niveau wie soll man das ausdrücken behandlung
kannst du nicht 80 millionen leute über eine gesetzliche krankenversicherung bezahlen wie
soll das denn funktionieren du musst dafür sorgen dass die leute eine ordentliche behandlung
bekommen und dass sie sich nicht wie beim artsfilm wie dass der typ keinen bock auf
sie hat ja aber du kannst nicht dafür sorgen dass jeder von 80 millionen zum welt zum
zusammen auch so kann deutschland einen speziellen besten spezialist gehen kann genau wieso
sollte man den reichen das recht wegnehmen wie gesagt verstehe ich auch nicht also du
hast das recht freie verträge zu machen auch mit medizinern und wenn du zum zu der absoluten
kori fair in deutschland gehen möchtest dass dich 150.000 euro kostet meinetwegen kannst
du machen aber trotzdem sollte dafür gesorgt werden dass die dass der durchschnitt ordentlich
versorgt wird und nicht so wie das jetzt teilweise der fall ist leider vermute ich mal dass meine
antwort genau das hier aussagen soll nämlich ich bin dafür dass die leute die sich nicht
leisten können scheiße behandelt werden und alle anderen gut das ist aber eigentlich
genau nicht das was ich damit nicht sagen will aber gut na gut also regierung sollten
unternehmen bestrafen die die öffentlichkeit täuschen ja also da haben wir ja viele viele
beispiele für die aussage alter tommy ich habe glaube ich jetzt 20 minuten erzählt
wie ich das gerne hätte kannst mir noch nicht ernsthaft vorwerfen ich wäre dafür die leute
sollen scheiße behandelt werden also wie deckt sich das auch nur ansatzweise mit dem
was die letzten 20 minuten erzählt habe also da gibt es ja schöne schöne beispiele für
die regierung sollte sich übrigens auch selbst bestrafen wenn man wieder irgendwelche daten
geleakt werden oder irgendwelche sachen nicht gemacht werden die versprochen wurden oder
so außerdem wir wissen ja gibt leute stehen auf bestrafen also wenn zum wenn es zum beispiel
irgendwelche daten leaks gibt die entgegen gelten der bestimmung nicht ordentlich kommuniziert
werden die versucht werden klein zu reden die versuchen ich nehme es einfach mal datenleaks
als beispiel wo versucht wird da irgendwie noch kapital zu schlagen ja da bin ich dafür
das sollte man nicht durchgehen lassen gibt sicherlich auch andere punkte ja ja da bin
ich da bin ich dafür und gerade öffentlichkeit täuschen da spielt ja vieles spielt ja vieles
also absichtlich dinger vertuschen die sonst für ein unangenehme folgen hätten finde ich
sollte nicht sein nichtsdestotrotz wird es das immer geben ein echt freier markt benötigt
beschränkungen die verhindern das multinationalen unternehmen monopole schaffen ja prinzipiell
schon aber gerade im technik sektor sieht man aktuell dass es irgendwie wieder wieder
den trend gibt zu ich leute ich sag jetzt was ich hab ich hab ein bisschen in wirtschaft
aufgepasst ich hab ein bisschen in wirtschaft aufgepasst das nennt sich an oligopol ich
weiß krass bvl big brain stels also sprich es gibt nicht einen großen sondern es gibt
ein paar große und das problem was ist da genau wenige das problem was da öfters auftreten
kann ist dass sie untereinander dinger absprechen aber ja ich monopole an sich sind für uns
nicht gut das hat man bei intel und cpus gesehen was intel jahrelang mit cpus gemacht hat und
kaum ist am d auch am start funktioniert das ganze allerdings könnte man das auch wieder
als beispiel nehmen für dass es eben keine beschränkung und regel braucht weil mit amd
hat sie auch so funktioniert aber trotzdem ich denke gewisse regelungen dazu sind sinnvoll
ich würde sogar mal sogar deutliche zustimmung machen chain war über was beschwerst du dich
ich mache nie deutliche zustimmung habe ich doch gerade gemacht leute ich habe zeit ich
bin heute ein bisschen länger aber kein problem so also abtreibung auf jetzt jetzt kommen
die die hardcore die hardcore ethischen questions alda abtreibung sollte immer illegal sein
wenn das leben der mutter nicht gefährdet ist moment also was ist jetzt zustimmung
und und nicht zustimmung aber sollte immer illegal sein nee schwierig kann man nicht
fragen skippen triggert kann man nicht kann man kann man nicht kann man nicht kann man
nicht das ist eine schwierige frage ich habe da keine ultimative antwort drauf es ist
es ist alles problematisch also es gibt sicherlich sehr viele argumenten für und dagegen es
ergibt ja auch keine usa eine relativ große bewegung wo es darum gibt quasi dass es dass
das alles alles verwerflich und illegal sein sollte also ich tendiere tatsächlich eher
zu ablehnung dass es nicht immer illegal ist aber ich möchte das nicht in irgendeiner
art und weise bewerten welche gründe nun gute gründe für sind das ist schwierig zu
beantworten ja
aber ich werde auch nicht sagen deutliche ablehnung das ist ein echt schwieriges thema
jede autorität sollte hinterfragt werden ja das ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt da wisst
ihr ich als alte hacker man ist da natürlich prinzipiell dafür
auge um auge zahn um zahn nein das ist schwachsinn aber die bibel leute das hat jesus gar nicht
gesagt oder wer hat das denn gesagt weiß mal wer das gesagt hat keine ahnung jesus war
der mit der bakke mose ist ja ganz bestimmt montana plege mit sicherheit kommt das nicht
aus dem arabischen wahrscheinlich eher aus dem hebräischen oder so aber vielleicht auch
ein schimmer also prinzipiell finde ich das würde ich der sache nicht zustimmen weil das
automatisch auch selbstjustiz im großen stil bedeuten würde und das finde ich keine sinnvolle
geschichte ja weil dann sind wir bei du hast ehre verletzt ich erschießt sich und solche
dinger das muss ja echt nicht sein das ist nichts im zweck wir haben gerichte wir haben
eine polizei das muss man nicht selbst regeln wann besuchst du mal monta was das für eine
frage also erstens werde ich nicht eingeladen und zweitens möchte ich da ehrlich gesagt
ich hin wir kennen uns nicht wirklich wir kennen uns von der gamescom pama was soll ich da
so steuerzahler sollten keine theater oder museen finanzieren müssen die sich wirtschaftlich
nicht selbst tragen können warum nicht ich weiß das ist vielleicht ein bisschen widersprüchlich
weil ich früher so pro wirtschaft und sonst was war ich finde das prinzipiell gar nicht
verkehrt wenn man dinger die wichtig für die allgemeinheit sind was hier unter dem
anderen theater und also theater vielleicht weniger museen schon wenn man die anteilmäßig
mit bezahlt ich meine man bezahlt so viel scheiße mit auf den ich nicht mit bezahlen
will ja und sachen die ich die ich gerne mit bezahlen würde wie zum beispiel ordentlich
den internet ausbau ja übrigens ich sehe das bei krankenhäusern ähnlich ja also sprich
auch krankenhäuser sind für mich nichts was big stonks wahnsinns gewinne machen muss
natürlich ist es vielleicht nicht sinnvoll ein riesengroßes krankenhaus irgendwo hinzusetzen
wo immer nur fünf prozent belegt ist also die total bescheuert geplant sind aber man
sollte sich wo man da wieder vorher bei anderen fragen sie man sollte sich schon an dem orientieren
was man zur verzuordentlichen versorgung infrastrukturellen versorgung der bevölkerung braucht und da würde
ich sagen kann museum durchaus auch dazu gehören und da finde ich nicht schlimm wenn das mit
steuergeldern bezahlt wird wohlgemerkt das zeug sollte nicht komplett schwachsinnig
gemanagt werden so nach dem motto wir stellen jetzt hier was aus was vielleicht nur einer
von irgendwie einer sehen will das ist klar aber wenn man sagt hey die versuchen das ganze
plus minus null zu halten kommen aber nicht hin und man zahlt ein bisschen was drauf das
finde ich nicht verkehrt ok also mal ablehnung keine sollten keine ja genau passt
schulen sollten keine anwesenheit was das für eine frage noch mehr analfabeten oder was
nee basti das beißt sich doch überhaupt nicht wenn krankenhäuser nicht gewinnorientiert
arbeiten also wenn krankenhäuser plus minus null rauskommen können bisschen was zugeschossen
werden hält es doch keiner von ab wenn er reich ist mit irgendeinem super experten in
einem in einem gebiet sich besser behandeln zu lassen das eine oder das andere mit nichts
zu tun und sicherlich ist es auch nicht verkehrt ich würde es übrigens im krankenhaus auch
nicht verbieten zu sagen hey du sollst gewinnorientiert arbeiten oder so aber das das das hauptsächlich
gezielt dass er was ich ja versucht habe bei der anderen frage vorher schon zu sagen sollte
es sein dass man die bevölkerung ordentlich versorgt ja für mich ich würde krankenhäuser
mal zu infrastruktur mit zählen aber du wirst es nicht vermeiden können dass leute die
richtig dick fette kohle haben sich eben bessere behandlung kaufen können aber warum sollten
die schule keine anwesenheitspflicht haben das ist doch bescheuert dann hast du dann
dann hast du dann noch mehr leute die die sagen ich muss nicht lesen und schreiben können
weil mein mann kann das oder wie oder meinen die anwesenheit ja moment meinen die physische
präsenz oder was also meinen die damit schulpflicht abschaffen oder meinen die damit du musst
nicht vor ort sein das ist nicht so ganz klar weil du hast natürlich anwesenheitspflicht
und wenn das jetzt grad in corona zeiten daheim gemacht wird dann ist es dann ist das für
mich auch anwesend und wenn die schulpflicht abschaffen meinen da bin ich nicht dafür
auch wenn ich nicht sondern ich gerne die schule gegangen bin ja wenn zum schulpflicht
geht da nicht also alle menschen haben ihre rechte aber es ist besser für uns alle wenn
verschiedene arten von von menschen unter sich warum ganz ehrlich ich würde nicht so
weit gehen dass jemand vorzuschreiben ist das wieder nazifrage oder sklavenhaltungsfrage
oder so also ich würde es den leuten nicht vorschreiben wenn jetzt einer sagt ich ich
will mit irgendwie anderen nichts zu tun haben ja meinetwegen
die frage ist tatsächlich wenn ich mir ein bisschen länger gedankend rüber mache gar
nicht so einfach überlegt euch mal irgendwelche irgendwelche siedlung in berlin mit 90 prozent
ausländeranteil
ist vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll
ja das schwierig so einfach ist die frage dann tatsächlich gar nicht
also beim ersten gebe ich ihn auf jeden fall recht also ich ich würde das prinzipiel ich
würde da prinzipiell nicht zustimmen dass das hört sich so ein bisschen von der formulierung
her schon so an so nach dem motto du solltest quasi so die die rassen trennen und rein
halten und was auch immer das ist das geht so das ist schon ein bisschen so die nazifrage
vermutlich mal aber nachdem sich so 100 prozentig klar ist dass man so gute eltern müssten
ihre kinder manchmal nein was ist für eine frage
es ist natürlich wenn kinder ein paar geheimnisse vor ihren eltern haben ja ja ist es wo ist
das problem du musst den eltern nicht alles erzählen ja genau ja und jetzt ok der besitz
von mariana oh leute der kann endlich mal eine frage der ich deutlich zustimmen kann
also ich bin überhaupt nicht dafür dass man kinder kinder einsteuern sollte chat wieder
die primäre funktion der schule sollte seine zukünftige generation mit fähigkeit zu nein
das ist auch so ein ding geht vielleicht auch ein bisschen meiner pro wirtschaft ansicht
ja weibnation also hier definitiv weibnation also es ist ja im prinzip das was die schule
aktuell macht die frage ist halt ihr ob das auch so sein sollte also ich denke es geht
tatsächlich ein bisschen entgegen dem was ich vorhin gesagt habe weil ich ja sehr pro
wirtschafts ist aber ich bin nicht der meinung dass die schule wie soll man sagen so zucht
becken für die wirtschaft sein sollte die schule sollte da dafür sorgen dass ich muss
mal gucken wie ich das irgendwie halbwegs dass man dass man versteht wie ich das meine ausdrücke
schule sollte dafür sorgen dass die leute zu zu eigenständig im denken und sagen eigenständig
denken und erkennen ist ein doofes wort in der lage sind also sprich dass die leute in
der lage sind eigenständig sich sachen anzueignen zu überprüfen zu lernen zu gucken und ihr
leben ordentlich leben zu können unter anderem auch in allen beziehungen das was den leuten
halt gut liegt und was nicht das ist ja eine sache die kommt relativ kurz so weder stream
ist morgen nicht als video online das weiß ich noch nicht so was ist immer so ist hier
kann man bestimmt sehr viele sachen aus dem kontext rausschneiden genau da seid das triffts
glaube ich ganz gut die schule sollte nicht hauptsächlich nur dafür da sein irgendwie
das ran zu züchten was man im job braucht da geht nämlich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
auch die innovation verloren also wenn du leute nur ausbildst auf die sachen die aktuell
gerade gebraucht werden hast du vielleicht für die sachen die morgen gebraucht werden
nix und du hast keine leute die wirklich neue ansätze neue ideen haben oder big brain sachen
machen also nee da würde ich da würde ich ablehnung ich würde nicht unbedingt so weit
gehen sagt deutliche ablehnung ein gewisser fokus auf das was man job mäßig braucht
ist nicht verkehrt ja und auch essentiell relevant dass man den leuten da was in der
richtung beibringen aber es sollte nicht einzig einzig allein das ziel sein du interpretierst
die frage wieder falsch das heißt du bist jetzt die hoheit darüber wie man diese frage
richtig interpretieren oder wie so menschen mit ernsthafter erb erkrankung sollte es nicht
gestattet sein sich fort zu pflanzen das ist wieder das ist wieder eine frage ich würde
ich würde sagen nein also dass ich der dass ich die sache ablehne es machen viele leute
freiwillig aber das prinzipiell nicht erlauben würde ich mir nicht anmaßen darüber zu entscheiden
es gibt welche die machen das freiwillig die wissen dass sie irgendwelche erbkrankheiten
haben und die sind dann aber auch schon älter sagen absichtlich nein ich möchte keine
kinder bekommen aber es ist ja was anderes
das mein ob die kinder auch alternativen schrott wie bäume umarmen naja das ist jetzt eine
ganz schön weit fast recht interpretation der sache von es sollte nicht nur zur jobfindung
dienen zu wir umarmen äume wie umarmen umarmen bäume chat also das ist ja vielleicht ein
bisschen dann dann auch ein bisschen ein bisschen weit ausgeholt normaler ablehnung gegenüber
deutscher ablehnung ist halt wenn du der idee etwas abgewinnen kannst wir sind wieder dabei
es gibt nur es gibt nur schwarz und weiß verstehe dass er das was mich war was ich
immer gerne habe wenn du nicht deutlich genug zu was nein sagst bist du dann jetzt bist
du deines neuerdings schon dafür dass es ja auch so eine diskussion dies auf twitter
ganz gerne gibt ja so nach dem motto irgendwas ganz schreckliches ist passiert jeder der
nicht sofort mindestens 250 seitlichen aufsatz darüber veröffentlicht warum das ganz furchtbar
verwerflich ist ist ist heimlich dafür ja das ist so die twitter logik das war blödsinn
menschen mit ernsthaft der markt soll nicht gestartet haben sich vor zu pflanzen man könnte
tatsächlich so weit gehen zu deutliche ablehnung also prinzipiell verbieten solltest du es
keinem dass es ist halt wenn es null prozent und 100 prozent gibt also sag mal so wenn
wenn 100 0 prozent ist komplette ablehnung dir fällt nicht ein einziger grund ein wo
man da pro bringen könnte und 100 prozent ist quasi komplett deutliche zustimmung da
würde ich sagen das ist dann schon eher so bei 10 prozent aber zum beispiel ich habe
ziviliens gemacht dass dort waren leute wirklich mit übelsten erbkrankheiten aber auch mit
nicht unbedingt wie soll ich sagen der geistigen auffassungsgabe dass sie diese frage überhaupt
verstehen würden also hat es da leute die waren im prinzip nicht in der lage irgendwie
ihre umwelt richtig wahrzunehmen aber die hätten sich durchaus fortpflanzen können
und das ist echt eine ultra ultra krasse frage zu sagen will man das solche leuten
verbieten ist wer maß sich überhaupt an darüber entscheiden zu wollen das zu verbieten
oder nicht das ist eine frage die kann man so echt schwer beantworten also ich bin für
deutliche ablehnung ich würde es aber gelten lassen wenn wenn es wenn man dort pro punkte
findet wo man sagen könnte das ist nicht komplett abwegig zu sagen hey in irgendwie total abgedrehten
fällen könnte man da doch darüber reden es ist wie immer es ist nicht nur nichts null
und nicht 100 prozent ich bin da zwar prinzipiell komplett dagegen so grundlegende rechte quasi
leuten fort zu enthalten ist schwierig ja wenn du es gelten lässt dann müsste incest
ja auch erlaubt das gibt bestimmt die eine andere leute haben die haben super argumente
für warum incest richtig poggers ist ich kann mir zwar keinen vorstellen mag es aber
geben
schwer schwierige frage
ok mal weiter das wichtigste für ein kind ist dass es lernen disziplin zu das ist das
ist die geschichte das wichtigste für ein kind ist dass es lernen disziplin zu also wenn
es danach geht wenn es danach geht habe ich das nie gelernt ich bin immer noch so ultra
fauler sack alda die übersetzung ist komisch ja gut kann sich umschalten verliert die fragen
ok also weiter es gibt keine zivilisierten und zivilisierten folter es gibt nur verschiedene
kulturen das ist das ist definitionsfrage dieser wörter wenn zivilisiert bedeutet
sagen wir unsere weltanschauung vertreten und so war das ja auch wenn man sich das mal
anguckt in der vergangenheit oftmals hat man das darunter verstanden also quasi wer so
unsere unsere weltanschauung vertreten wenn nur das als zivilisiert gilt gibt es mit
sicherheit zivilisiert unzivilisiert das ist das ist eine reine definitionsfrage was
man von diesem wort versteht ja es gibt sicherlich unzivilisierte menschen die sich auffüllen
wie die achste walde ich würde da prinzipiell sogar zustimmen weil es halt ganz stark an
der definition der wörter hängt ja mit zivilisiert verbindet man in der regel immer so die eigene
kultur und nur was das quasi macht ist ist zivilisiert und jetzt irgendwie nen auf der
anderen seite muss ich halt sagen jetzt wenn ich das sage es gibt schon ein paar sachen
die ich als unzivilisiert empfinde ja die ich dich auch nicht gut für Leute enthaupten
oder generell todestrafe ist was da kann ich der sache kann ich gar nichts abgewinnen
das ist schon was wo ich sage mit das ist für mich unzivilisiert ja so an meinem maßstab
maßstab und der frankfurter hauptbahnhof ist auf jeden fall auch nicht zivilisiert ja
genau oder zum beispiel länder wo du was weiß ich ohne mann nicht auf die straße darfst
oder was auch immer es gibt sachen die finde ich nicht sinnvoll ja die finde ich auch an
meinem maßstab würde ich sie nicht als zivilisiert beschreiben es sind definitiv unterschiedliche
kulturen aber ich muss es ja nicht toll finden die werner von siemens schule ist auch nicht
die werner von siemens schule ist auch nicht zivilisiert das hängt und steht und fällt
aber mit mit der definition von zivilisiert was was was ist denn darunter offiziell gemeint
zeitmeier zivilisiert wir gucken jetzt beim duden alter big brain move also ein äußerst
ja ja was jetzt fein fein gesittet höflich kultiviert ja nutella erschnitte ich finde
viele fragen da nicht zornig super nicht soll ich gut formulieren fein gesittet höflich
kultiviert ok wenn man mal die ersten dinger nimmt fein gesittet höflich dann muss ich
sagen da gibt es sicherlich genug der test ist mi stress change my mind ja ich finde
es auch nicht gut weil das problem bei diesen fragen ist oftmals dass du das eine nehmen
müsstest aber so viele punkte dafür sprechen dass du das eigentlich nehmen kannst aber
die andere hälfte der nur dann zustimmen wird es auch nicht ist es ist doof aber gut
machen wir mal weiter die frage ist ziemlich unkultiviert menschen die arbeiten können
es aber verweigern sollten keine gesellschaftliche unterstützung erhalten wir haben zeit leute
heute übrigens wisst ihr was ich geil finde chat wie viele immer so bei so bei so einfachen
dingern wo man nicht einer meinung sind so übelst auf 180 sind auch schon wieder im
chat also menschen die arbeiten können es aber verweigern sollten keine gesellschaftliche
unterstützung also gut die frage ist zumindest relativ klar gestellt also also wenn leute
arbeiten können aber sagen ich mache einfach gar nichts als es ja im endeffekt auch so
viel wie fickt euch allgemeinheit da gibt es jetzt auch absolut null um die gründe warum
jemand das nicht kann wenn wir jetzt mal einfach von dem fall ausgehen dass jemand könnte
also da absolut nichts im weg steht sei es irgendwelche körperlichen psychischen sonst
was probleme die aber nicht dazu also die nicht ausreichen dass man quasi offiziell
als arbeitsunfähig erklärt wird dann würde ich sagen ja ich finde das sollte man nicht
unbedingt noch fördern dass man sich die eier schaukelt da stimme ich immer gehe ich zumindest
mal in die zustimmungsrichtung
sind reiche leute arbeiten gehen die meisten werden es mit sicherheit machen ja genau
das sehe ich auch so was haben wir die nächste frage das übrigens noch eines dazu es hat
ja auch kund warum die leute reich sind natürlich gibt leute die erben das aber haben zumindest
die vorfahren etwas geleistet schon das kommt ja das wächst ja nicht auf dem baum so also
wenn ein etwas bedrückt ist es besser nicht darüber nachzudenken und sich mit fröhlicheren
sachen zu beschäftigen wenn ein etwas bedrückt ist es besser nicht darüber nachzudenken
und sich mit fröhlicheren sachen zu beschäftigen also ich meine das macht doch jeder so das
das macht doch jeder mal oder also wer hat nicht schon gesagt fack ich muss morgen ich
muss morgen eine arbeit schreiben ich gucke jetzt lieber ein video von max oder sowas
in der richtung also wenn ein etwas bedrückt ist es besser nicht darüber nachzudenken
und sich mit fröhlichen sachen zu beschäftigen es kommt drauf an muss man das ist es ein
problem was das hängt ganz entscheidend wenn es ein problem ist was man lösen muss dann
ist es sicherlich nicht sinnvoll sich permanent über andere sachen gedanken zuzumachen wird
man sich früher oder später mit beschäftigen müssen aber ist es weil eine freundin verlassen
hat oder sowas um einen punkt zu nennen dann ist es tatsächlich besser sich nicht so viele
gedanken drüber zu machen sondern irgendwas zu zu machen was was ein wo man gut drauf
ist also das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an was ein betrückt das ist das das das kann
das kann von deutlicher ablehnung bis zu deutliche zustimmung gehen das ist komplett situationsabhängig
nachdem ich ja auch ein meister wie nennt man das so schön pro pro krastinierer bin
schreibt man das so genau nachdem ich meister im pro krastinieren bin kenne ich mich damit
sehr gut aus vor sachen auf die ich keinen bock habe auszublenden deswegen stimme ich
da jetzt einfach mal zu sagen wir mal so objektiv gesehen wäre es besser sich damit zu beschäftigen
aber aus meiner eigenen erfahrung ja ok was haben jetzt migranten der ersten generation
die im ausland geboren wurden können nie vollständig in was moment migranten der ersten
generation die im ausland geboren wurden können nie vollständig in einem neuen land
integriert werden das das hängt das das hängt an so vielen faktoren und das hängt natürlich
auch an den leuten wenn alle wenn die voraussetzungen gut sind und auf fruchtbaren boden fallen
ist das kein problem das funktioniert ich kenne genug leute gerade früher bei mir in
der schule hatten wir beispielsweise ein paar die sind aus dem was war das für kosovow
kosovo krieg zum beispiel geflohen gut das ist jetzt kulturell nicht so krass weit weg
von uns der typ der hat besser deutsch gesprochen nach einem halben jahr als ich dario hieser
weiß ich noch der dekter war krasse der war der ist dann auch irgendwann hessischer hat
irgendwelche hessischen tennis meisterschaften oder sowas gewonnen aber übelst der war übelst
den teile des funktioniert also müssen halt alle seiten mitmachen das ist klar also dann
was was ok was können nie vollständig damit das denke ich nicht das kann funktionieren
wichtig ist dass beide seiten mitmachen wenn du wenn du leute hast die nicht wollen dann
funktioniert das nicht wenn du eine gesellschaft hast die nicht mitmacht dann funktioniert
das auch nicht das muss das muss auf beiden seiten zusammenkommen
Aber das geht, das habe ich schon gesehen, das ist gar kein Problem, wenn alle wollen.
Wenn man natürlich lieber im Berliner Ghetto unterwegs ist, dann ist es schwierig, aber
wenn alle Seiten wollen, dann geht das.
So, was gut für die erfolgreichen Unternehmen ist, ist im Endeffekt gut für uns alle.
Ne, ne, nicht wirklich, nur weil irgendein Autohersteller Big Stonks macht und auf oder
sagen wir mal, ein ganz, ganz doofes Beispiel, nur weil in einem Chemieunternehmen die Leute
ohne Atemschutzmasken arbeiten und das richtig finanziell richtig prumpf für die, heißt
es noch lange nicht, dass das gut ist für die und für uns alle.
Ne, keine Sendeanstalt, egal wie unabhängig sie sind, sollte staatliche Unterstützung
erhalten.
Tja, ich bin echt kein Freund unseres öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkzwangsbeitrages, ich finde es aber
den prinzipiellen Ansatz gar nicht verkehrt, nur die Ausprägung bei uns ist fragwürdig.
Es kommt mittlerweile leider regelmäßig vor, dass Leute ins Gefängnis müssen, weil sie
den Rundfunkbeitrag nicht bezahlen.
Das ist was, wo ich sagen, wo ist die Verhältnismäßigkeit aus, keine Ahnung, 500 Euro offenen Rundfunkbeiträgen.
What?
Ja, die Leute müssen in den Knast, weil sie den Rundfunkbeitrag nicht bezahlen.
Ich glaube der WDR war es, Rundfunkverweigerergefängnis, ja, was noch immer in der Nordkorea ist,
keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das, Georg T., also das ist was, wo ich halt sage, wo ist das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise noch verhältnismäßig.
Und dann ist die Frage, wie unabhängig sind, in Anführung geschrieben, unabhängige, wenn
sie eben auch so Kohle angewiesen sind und Politik, die da mitmacht.
Das ist, also, also ich finde die ursprüngliche Sache sinnvoll.
Also ich finde, wenn man sagt, hey, wir finanzieren mit Steuergeldern quasi Informations, wir
produzieren so Informationsgehalt, also Sachen mit Informationsgehalt für die Leute, finde
ich das durchaus eine sinnvolle Sache und das würde ich auch unter dem Punkt Infrastruktur
irgendwie abhaken, aber unsere Ausprägung davon finde ich übertrieben und dass Leute
den Rundfunkbeitrag nicht bezahlen, im Gefängnis landen, für 500 Euro oder so, finde ich unter
aller Sau und das ist was, was ich nicht unterstützen möchte, was ich leider machen muss.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, wir sind, ich muss das halt für unsere, für unsere Situation
hier jetzt als Grundlage nehmen, würde ich sagen, also keine Senderanschalt, egal wie
unabhängig ihr denn sein solltet, nein, also da würde ich, da würde ich immer noch, auch
wenn ich das überhaupt nicht mag, wie das hier läuft und ich das unter aller Sau finde,
wie wir das umgesetzt haben und ich auch bei uns Zweifel habe, wie unabhängig das teilweise
ist, würde ich aber trotzdem sagen, dass ich das prinzipielle Konstrukt nicht verkehrt
finde.
Okay, NEXT, ja ja, ich hab noch ein bisschen Zeit heute, unsere Bürgerrechte werden übermäßig
für die Terrorabwehr eingeschränkt.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man das mal auf Corona bezieht, wir beziehen das jetzt einfach mal
auf Corona und nicht auf Terrorabwehr, ich glaube Terror ist glaube aktuell, zumindest
jetzt zur aktuellen Zeit nicht mehr so angesagt, wir können, nennen wir es mal generell Gefahrenabwehr,
okay?
Sagen wir Gefahrenabwehr, nennen wir es einfach mal, also sei es jetzt Corona, sei es Terrorabwehr
oder was, nennen wir es mal Gefahrenabwehr, da muss ich sagen, ja, da bin ich, ich würde
nicht sagen deutliche Zustimmung, aber da würde ich prinzipiell schon zustimmen, gerade
was den Punkt Datenschutz angeht, und ich finde es übrigens immer noch ein Unding,
das Edward Snowen in Russland versauert, ja, und wir sagen, juckt uns alles nicht, und
auch zig gefailte Projekte von, was weiß ich, angefangen von Corona, Aufenthaltsdaten,
die dann doch an die Polizei wieder weitergegeben wurden, obwohl das eigentlich nicht passieren
sollte, oder irgendwelche anderen gefailten IT-Projekte, irgendwelchen Leaks, irgendwie,
wir brauchen Möglichkeiten jeglichen Datenverkehr zu entschlüsseln und solche Sachen, da würde
ich in dem Fall tatsächlich auch in die Richtung tendieren, dass dort oftmals über das Ziel
hinaus geschossen wird, hinaus geschossen wird, passt ja dazu, was denke ich aber auch
an zwei Sachen liegt, einmal, dass wir sicherlich wieder krass Lobbyarbeit am Start haben, und
dass wir aber auch Politiker am Start haben, die gerade was IT-Themen angeht, keine Ahnung
haben. Ja, also stelle ich prinzipiell zu. Ein signifikanter Vorteil eines Einparteienstaates,
ist, dass alle Diskussionen in dem Fortschritt wenigstens vermieden werden. Da wäre ich mir
nicht zu sicher, auch gerade bei den China-Chinesen nicht. Natürlich Fortschritt in Form von Wirtschaftswachstum
und sonst was, aber es gibt sicherlich genug Dinger, da geht in China gar nichts mehr, weil
das nicht quasi der allgemeinen Marschrichtung entspricht. Da kommen dann so Dinger raus,
wie dieses Krankenhaus mit den Bagger. China-Bagger-Krankenhaus, wo dann einfach für ein gutes Foto, random
60 Bagger auf den Platz gestellt werden, die einfach nichts machen. Also erstens, die
könnten gar nicht baggern, so eng wie die beieinander stehen, und zweitens, wie man hier
sieht, die baggern auch irgendwie nichts. Ich glaube nicht, dass das ein signifikanter
Vorteil ist, außer ganz andere Probleme. Ich mache nicht deutliche Ablehnung, weil es sicherlich
Punkte gibt, wo das echt ein Vorteil ist, hingegen zu unserer übertriebenen Bürokratie.
Aber ich würde nicht so weit gehen und sagen, jawoll, Kekonad-Verhältnisse beste.
Obwohl das elektronische Zeitalter Überwachungsmaßnahmen einfacher macht, müssen sich nur Leute,
die etwas zu verbergen haben, darum sorgen. Nein. Nein. Auf gar keinen Fall.
Kann doch auch Bürokratie in einem Einparteienstaat geben. Ja, das stimmt, aber wenn den Regierenden
dort die Bürokratie nicht in den Plan passt, dann wird sie einfach übersprungen oder derjenige,
der es falsch entscheidet, wird erschossen. Das hast du bei uns nicht. Deswegen können
die Chinesen in zwei Tagen oder in zwei Wochen ein Krankenhaus bauen und wir brauchen dafür
zwei Jahre. Er hat alles seine vorderen Teile, aber ich bevorzuge die Art und Weise, wo keiner
dafür erschossen wird. So. Obwohl das, also genau, da bin ich deutlicher
Ablehnung, das betrifft alle und nicht nur Leute, die etwas zu verbergen haben.
Die Todesstrafe sollte eine Bestrafungsmöglichkeit, nein, da bin ich nicht dafür. Ich finde Todesstrafe
an sich für nichts, für nichts die passende Antwort. Zumal es auch keine wirklichen Verbrechen
verhindert. Das eigentliche Ziel sollte ja sein, natürlich wirst du es nicht schaffen,
genug Verrückte. Das eigentliche Ziel sollte ja daraufhin gewirkt werden, dass weniger solcher
Verbrechen begangen werden und Todesstrafe nutzt auf jeden Fall nichts dafür, dass Verbrechen
zurückgehen. Und man spart übrigens auch keine Kosten im Knast. Das stimmt nicht.
Ein Todeskandidat in den USA ist teurer als einer im Knast. Der kostet mehr. Zumindest
in Kokonaland. Aber Todesstrafe ist was, da kann ich absolut nichts mit anfangen. Und
das gehört beispielsweise für mich auch zu unzivilisiert. Wenn man lebenslang eingesperrt
wird, das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube aber schon. Da müsste ich jetzt genauer nachgucken.
Ich weiß nur, dass es ein ganz schön teurer Spaß ist das zu haben und das zu machen. Guckt
mal nach. Ich habe da mal was drüber gelesen. Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, ja es ist so,
auch bei lebenslänglich Leuten, aber es ist verdammt teuer. In einer zivilisierten Gesellschaft
hat der Einzelne immer Vorgesetzte, denen zu folgen ist und untergeben die zu. Ist das
die Sklavenhaltungsfrage? Ist das die Zulullfrage oder was ist das? Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das war
fast das Slave-Frage anscheinend. Also nein. Jeder sollte die Möglichkeit haben, das zu
machen was er will. Er muss es aber auch selbst nutzen. Abstrakte Kunst, die nichts darstellt,
ist überhaupt nicht als Kunst angesehen. Ne, warum? Wisst ihr warum ich nicht deutliche
Ablehnungen mache? Es gibt Kunst, die finde ich tatsächlich ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Wo ich sagen würde, die hat keinen Mehrwert irgendwie. Was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt gegen
die Wand kacke und mache da ein Foto von und sage, das ist geile Kunst. Es gibt ja nicht
umsonst, wenn du ein Patent anmeldest, gibt es ja noch dieses Hindernis, dass es die nötige
Stöpfungshöhe aufweisen muss. Und so sehe ich das da auch ein bisschen. Also es gibt
schon verdammt viel Scheiße, wo ich mir denke, das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Aber ich würde
nicht so weit gehen und sagen, ja abstrakte Kunst ist prinzipiell schlecht, weil es da
sicherlich auch die ein oder anderen wirklich guten Big Brain Sachen gibt. Zum Beispiel
könnte man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ist Overwatch-Porn Kunst oder nicht? Also, äh,
ich habe Ablehnung. Außerdem, außerdem, eine Sache, die ich noch dazu sagen muss,
außerdem, ähm, sollten das die Leute entscheiden, die sich für sowas interessieren. Also wenn
einer, super, wenn einer wahrgenommen hat, es scheißt wirklich einer gegen die Wand
und verkauft das dann und strickt da so eine geile Story rum, dass ihm einer 20 Millionen
für bezahlt, ja, well played, meinetwegen. Und dann interessiert es ja auch die beiden
nicht, ob das jetzt nun die restliche Welt als Kult ansieht oder nicht, ja. Also, in
der Strafjustiz sollte Bestrafung wichtiger sein als Rehabilitation. Rehabilitation heißt
soviel wie Wiedergutmachung oder, oder, oder, oder, äh, Wiedereinkliederung oder, oder,
was ist das genau? Wiedereinkliederung, Einkliederung. Ähm, also, das Extreme davon wäre ja, wenn
du sagst, ähm, komplette Zustimmung bedeutet, quasi, wir machen für Verbrecher erstmal,
quasi Ferienlager mit, äh, Friede, Freude und wir haben uns alle so gerne und Therapie
und dann kann man sie super wieder einkliedern. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert.
Also, gibt es Länder, wo das funktioniert? Waren die das in Norwegen so? Und Neuseeland?
Das ist ein Thema, mit dem beschäftige ich mich nie. So irgendwie, äh, Strafvollzug
und was da für neueste Sachen gibt und so. Aber was ich mich dann frage ist, also wenn
das, wenn das in, wenn das, wenn das, sag mal so, wenn das in Schweden und so ganz gut
funktioniert, frage ich mich, mich würde interessieren, was denn beispielsweise Angehörige
von Opfern dazu sagen. Also sprich, reicht das denen oder? Ja, das stimmt, das, das hab
ich ja gerade gesagt, deswegen, wie gesagt, Todesstraf beispielsweise auch extrem teuer.
Also, wenn das funktioniert, wenn das funktioniert, ist das ja sicherlich eine super Geschichte.
Allerdings muss man auch immer davon ausgehen, das heißt, das ist wieder so, das kann man
schlecht, schlecht, schlecht wieder so für, für alle sagen. Es gibt sicherlich Leute,
bei denen ist Hopfen und Malz verloren. Ja, Jäger, da hast du nicht unrecht, wobei du
die ja, sag mal so, nicht selbst ausführst, ne? Also, das ist ja der Unterschied. Also,
wenn man jetzt hier, auf der anderen Seite, das sind so Fragen, wenn man da drüber nachdenkt,
sind die, sind die gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten. Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel hat
man, ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein bisschen fast-stretched, fast-stretched, ja, ein bisschen,
aber vielleicht wisst ihr, worauf ich raus will. Zum Beispiel hat man Anfang, glaub ich, noch,
vom 19. Jahrhundert, hat man Leute lobotomiert, die gewisse Neigungen hatten. Zählt das
auch als Rehabilitation dann, weil die danach nichts mehr anstellen? Das ist eine schwierige
Frage, oder? Na, das zählt nicht als Rehabilitation, ok? Aber die kann man, die kann man auch wieder
gut, die kann man auch wieder gut einkliedern. Die kannst du an die Supermarktkasse sicherlich
stellen und dann macht den ganzen Tag das, das eine Ding, was er machen soll. Die Strafe
ist in Schweden quasi, ah, Chat, das muss ich jetzt mal lesen, was? Die Strafe ist in
Schweden quasi die Arbeit für die Gesellschaft. Kaum ein Land muss so viel Sozialarbeit leisten
oder, ja, Sozialarbeit finde ich auch jetzt eine gute Strafe. Ja, bringt das was? Tja,
gut, was auch immer. Wenn der Ansatz funktioniert, warum nicht? Stimmt, Dark Side, das ist ein
guter Punkt. Leute, also wir reden jetzt ja nicht vom psychisch Gestörten, die andere
Leute rein aus Spaß umbringen, weil das Blut spritzt. Da kannst du mit Rehabilit... Rehabilitation
wahrscheinlich nicht viel machen, aber anderen Sachen sicherlich einiges. Hab ich mich nie
mit beschäftigt, deswegen erzähl ich jetzt auch nicht mehr zu. Also Zeitverschwendung
zu versuchen manche kriminelle zu rehabilitieren
also da gehe ich mal von moment da gehe ich mal auch von aus dass es bei manchen leuten schlicht und ergreif nicht funktioniert
also wenn du wenn du leute hast die
keine ahnung gerne andere leute abstechen weil weil sie gerne blut sehen
weil sie zu den 2 prozent gestörten gehören ich weiß nicht ob man da so viel machen kann
manche was ist da da was ist das für eine einschränkung also ich denke manche sachen kann man echt schlecht was machen das hängt immer von den voraussetzungen ab
will mich interessieren wie diese frage wie die frage in englisch ist
warst du schon beim impfzentrum am frankfurter hauptbahnhof maxi machen das sogar ehrenamtlich nee war schon nicht was soll ich da ich hab keinen termin ich werd mich hüten irgendwie in die nähe von corona leuten zu gehen solange ich nicht geimpft bin
übrigens meine mutter haben sie auch schon gefragt die war ja früher krankenschwester aber die hat gemeint sie ist mit vorerkrankung risikogruppe und macht sie nicht
was sie nicht verstanden am bahnhof gibt spritzen für alle acht das impfzentrum es hätte auch durchaus sein können dass es ein richtiges impfzentrum hauptbahnhof gibt leute das kann man jetzt echt falsch verstehen
der war aber nicht schlecht das gebe ich zu der war quasi so so big brain dass es mich schon hat also was haben wir denn unternehmen und hersteller sind wichtiger als warum gibt es da eigentlich keine
neutral warum gibt es da keine neutral button in diesem ganzen ding ich denke es ist beides wichtig eine gesellschaft braucht beides es ist ich will nicht so weit gehen und sagen das eine ist viel wichtiger als das andere man braucht beides man braucht eine ordentliche wirtschaft man braucht innovation man braucht
big brain leute aber man braucht allerdings auch big brain leute und kreative leute in beides gleich wichtig muss halt moment ja ok dann stürmen ab der recht ja und bei ablehn eigentlich dann für mich eher so ist ich anders wie als die andere seite ist wichtiger
mit der mütter dürfen karrieren haben aber ihre oberste pflicht ist die hausfrau ich wollte jetzt einen dummen spruch machen aber ich weiß das schneidet garantiert irgendjemand aus dem zusammenhang
raus ja deswegen lasse ich das jetzt unserfalls wirklich dazu denke selbstverständlich dürfen frauen machen was sie wollen und wenn zwei leute sich dazu entscheiden bingo zu machen und nachwuchs zu zeugen und sie irgendwie zu dem schluss kommen
es ist besser wenn man sich das teilt oder besser wenn das der kell macht oder sich irgendwie für die für die arme kinder pflege oder betreuung bestellen und beide das kind die beide eltern die sieht muss ich das nicht gut finden aber das können die komplett machen wie sie wollen
das heißt ja wenn ich jetzt ablehnung mache lehne ich da noch ab dass das das frauenkarriere machen dürfen oder lehne ich da generell ab das den was vorschreiben will
ich lehne ab aber ihre oberste pflicht ist die der hausfrau ok
das jetzt mensplained aber ich darf ja eigentlich leute eigentlich darf ich dazu gar nichts sagen ich darf dazu nichts sagen ich bin weiß männlich alt heterosexuell nicht veganer
was ist ja noch alles was bin ich ja noch alles boomer lehne aktose intolerant bin ich nicht
singel macht das dann unterschied ich habe ein bisschen geld reich bin ich nicht wirklich ich habe ein haus großgrundbesitzer da darf ich ja prinzipiell schon mal nichts zu sagen eigentlich
ich bin dick ich bin ich bin thick alda leute pepo fett max tutandt findest du spannend ich laber einfach nur rüber schön dass du da bist max tutandt
du fährst ein verbrenner das würde ich so nicht unterschreiben ich habe ein verbrenner ich fahre aber kein verbrenner ich habe sogar wenn man das mal rein vom
fahrzeugschein her nimmt sogar zwei verbrenner und ich fahre keinen von beiden zumindest nicht oft keckweight weil ich fahre mit der bahn also ich also wenn es um eine
sache geht wo mir echt keiner eins beimpinkeln kann ist es irgendwie meine umweltbilanz nein es stehen nicht zwei siehst du der chat interpretiert da schon mal wieder so geile sachen rein nein es stehen nicht zwei autos rum
mir gehören zwei autos das heißt nicht dass zwei autos bei mir rumstehen so chat ist wieder big brain interpretation stellt ok der chat will wissen was sache ist also ich erzähle es euch warum habe ich zwei autos
ich habe einmal mein mein mein opel agila und das andere auto gehört nur mir ich habe jemand geld geliehen dass er sich ein auto kaufen kann und nachdem er das jetzt über eine ganze weile zurück bezahlen muss gehört mir das auto so lang
also förderst du verbrenner auto ich ich fördere als erstes mal leute mit denen ich mich gut verstehe und die persönliche probleme haben in der situation
so das gefällt den leuten dass ich nun opel wisst ihr eigentlich was es für ein in einer heutigen maßung für ein kackauto ist in grün das ist nach heutigen maßstäben würde das keiner mehr anfassen
geschweige
ich bin auch dass der pock ist der ist und er ist ziemlich agil
also wenn du mit dem hundert fährst denkst du schon der kippt gleich um so wir machen weiter
der ist ich finde das auto super also für die für die für die größe hat man erstaunlich viel platz das ding ja wirklich klein und was ich gerne habe was ich auch auf jeden fall bei einem bei einem auto haben will wenn ich mir
noch mal eins holen würde oder wahrscheinlich holen werde weil da macht es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr ewig man sitzt ein bisschen höher das ist auf jeden fall eine super geschichte und das hätte ich gerne auch beim anderen auto
flex du damit vom club mehr wenn ich vom club flexe dann hole ich mein handy raus und zeigt meine youtube stonks kontaktliste von leuten ja und ich sage also krass was du für leute kennst oder ein easy easy
so das war mir erstmal den kram fertig boomer sitzen etwas gerne höher
also multinationale unternehmen beuten unethisch die pflanzen genetischen ressourcen der was moment die was die pflanzen genetischen
was für ein teil die was was in pflanzen genetische ressourcen
ich meine ihr könnt mir nicht sagen ich bin ich bin dumm weil ich das wort nicht kennen es gibt 100 9000 google treffer das ist nichts ich kann es halt auf englisch lesen da geht die antworten weg
aber ja ja machen wir machen wir und wir sind ja wir leben ja auch also wir beteiligen uns ja auch an dingern die ethisch sicherlich fragwürdig sind so nach dem motto hähnchenreste in südafrika oder in afrika nicht in südafrika in afrika abladen und sowas
also das ist schon fragwürdig was da an einigen stellen läuft ja machen wir mit dem establishment frieden zu schließen ist ein wichtiger aspekt des erwachsen werdens mit dem was zum teufel was wollt ihr denn von mir mit dem establishment
mit der elite mit der elite muss ich keine freundschaft schließen das sind äußerst eil fragen ja mit dem establishment frieden schließen ich muss mit gar keinem frieden schließen wenn ich nicht will
so wir haben jetzt wir haben noch kurzzeit also wenn du es bis hierhin geschafft hast dann diese thesen über religion jetzt astrologie erklärt viele dinge akkurat nein astrologie ist schwachsinn
wohlgemerkt astronomie nicht astrologie nicht astronomie also astrologie kann ich bloß sagen und man kann nicht moralisch sein ohne religiös zu sein doch das funktioniert ohne probleme
wohltätigkeit ist besser geeignet als sozialhilfe um die wirklich benachteiligten zu unterscheiden
also ich kenne mich weder mit sozialhilfe regelung aus noch weiß ich was die irgendwelche wohltätigkeit macht aber im zweifelsfall eher nicht weil ich keine ahnung habe was die kirche fördert außer vielleicht knaben köre oder so
die kirchen haben vor naturaus kein glück eines schwachsinn wisst ihr warum ich nicht wisst ihr warum ich nicht deutliche ablehnung mache es gibt einige leute die stellen sich habe ich zumindest absichtlich dumm an
und das könnte man ja ungefähr damit interpretieren die haben vor naturaus kein glück also manche leute stellen sich absichtlich doof an habe ich den eindruck manchmal und das sind sie irgendwie auch selbst dran schuld
es ist wichtig dass die schule meines kindes religiöse werte das ist mir scheißegal das ist mir vollkommen wurscht am liebsten wäre mir eine schule die da gar keinen all zu großen wert drauf legt auf die religiösen aspekte
aber aber auf wertevermittlung ja da sage ich nichts dagegen aber auf die religiösen aspekt muss nicht sein was ich auch nicht verkehrt finde ist wenn man sich in ethik über die religionen der welt unterhält und sich mal anguckt was sie so machen
das ist durchaus in ordnung aber ich will nicht dass der irgendwelche religiösen werte vermittelt werden alles so ethikunterricht ich hatte alles ich hatte religionsunterricht so richtig krassen katholischen religionsunterricht und ethik aber beide sind nicht dazu geführt dass ich irgendwie gläubig bin
so next ah gachi bass jetzt gehts ab wobei moment man gachit keine frauen das geht nicht aber steht ja hier nix von wir wollen ja keine gender assume so 6 außerhalb der ehe ist ungewöhnlich unmoralisch quatsch
irgendjemand hat gesagt die letzten frauen sind easy as fuck dann habt ihr recht ein gleichgeschlechtliches paar in einer stabilen liebenden beziehung sollte nicht von der möglichkeit einer kinderadoption ausgeschlossen werden
aber wenn sollte nicht das ist wieder voll nicht und sollte sollte nicht also sprich man ist dafür dass die ein kind adoptieren dürfen man ist dafür dass die kind adoptieren dürfen ja ich finde das prinzipiell keine schlechte idee
ich weiß aber nicht wie das aktuell bei uns rechtlich ausschaut weil es gilt ja immer noch nicht als ehe oder
also ich ich bin auf jeden fall prinzipiell dafür das ist was da würde ich beispielsweise gerne mal den fabian fragen was der zu sowas denkt da hat ja bei sowas oftmals teilweise ganz andere ansichten als man vielleicht zu erwarten würde ich bleibe jetzt erstmal da so
also pornografie die einwilligende erwachsenen soll sollte für die erwachsenen was moment noch mal pornografie die einwilligende erwachsene darstellt also wo beide wo beide das machen wollen
sollten für die erwachsene bevölkerung egal egal natürlich warum nicht wenn die freiwillig miteinander vor der kamera gachi bass und das ist auch ok ja die gachi bass variante ist auch vollkommen in ordnung
das doch vollkommen in ordnung wüsste gar nicht warum man das verbieten sollte
was sich im schlafzimmer zwischen zustimmenden erwachsenen abspielt geht den start nichts an was hat es den start anzugehen wer mit wem fickt also wenn irgendjemand verheiratet ist mit mit
irgendjemand verheiratet und treiben will das ist doch das ist doch nicht ihr ding also moment da hab ich mal geguckt es geht den überhaupt nichts an sind das denn das kokona fragen so nach dem motto wir brauchen eine kamera in jedem schlafzimmer
niemand kann sich von natur aus homosexuell fühlen klar warum nicht ja wo woher soll das denn sonst kommen woher soll das denn sonst in irgendeinem grund muss es ja haben bestimmt nicht weil irgendjemand mal einen gay porno gesehen hat und gedacht gedacht hat ich werde jetzt schwul es ist eher umgedreht jemand guckt sich da mal ein gay porno an denkt irgendwie findest du das geil
und dann denkt er sich vielleicht sollst du es mal ausprobieren irgendwann musst du es halt mal merken heute geht die offenheit über 6 zu weit juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht ich meine ganz ehrlich ich muss nicht alles wissen
ich muss ich muss nicht alles wissen ich brauche auch keine pool streams auf twitch und auch kein kein gamer girl badewasser also ich muss nicht alles wissen also ich also manche sachen müssen echt müssen echt nicht sein ich muss nicht alles wissen
ich also manche sachen müssen echt müssen echt nicht sein aber auf der anderen seite also ich würde niemals so weit gehen sagen ich will irgendwie da ein was vorschreiben was er machen soll ich wills ich wills aber ich will nicht unbedingt alles wissen ja heute geht die offenheit über 6 zu zur ablehnung
ok sollen wir mal sehen ok jetzt jetzt exzellent also jetzt kommts leute wachst bis zum morgen wieder an ja
was heißt es jetzt
ja ok hier ist hitler gut gut zu wissen
ich bin links libertär
und was genau ist das jetzt
einfach von mir bin ich auch schon mal froh gandhi ghandhi es war ohne scheiß soll ich euch mal was sagen ich bin riesengelangmumbles fan ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht wie nahe sich die beiden so waren ja
Passt doch
Warum deiner lama fern weil der deiner lama der einzige
Religionsanführer ist oft wird er dem ich folge weil ich sinnvoll finde was der für dinger über
Zwischenmenschliche
Zusammenleben schreibt
Bin ich fragwürdig die spiegel ist hier ok soll ich mir das mal angucken wo ich spiegel
Bicke ist da
Exzellent da ist spiegel ist rechts autoritärer spiegel so so ich bin da
Ist da mal Show chart in separate
Aber das war klar ich war ja schon ich war ja in manchen sachen schon relativ relativ
prowirtschaftsmäßig eingestellt
Ein
Test ist fake
Sher這麼 2017
Aber da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran.
Also die Fragen waren teilweise schon echt ziemlich ja Paynes Champ, ne?
naja gut was das zertifikat printable 0w nein was soll ich
denn printable ok ok ja der test war schon ein bisschen pepega muss ich sagen
kann ich in mein lebenslauf ich brauche kein lebenslauf ok leute morgen früh bin ich wieder
am start aufwachen stream eats wir sehen uns für das dass es kein stream war gucken aber
ganz schön viele leute zu wir machen vor der bundestagswahl den walumat 100 pro 1000
prozent ich ich schwör walla machen wir